Candid Truth.
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. And tonight we
got a very special guest, a new
apostolic reformation insider who's
about to blow the whistle, blow the lid
off everything. The new world order
agenda that's happening through the
church that's going to create the one
world religion. And it is coming sooner
than you think. This is crazy. I cannot
wait to get into this. Let me get my
guest in here. Minnow, what's up, man?
Thank you so much for being on the show
again.
Absolutely. It's a pleasure, man. Always
great to be on the show with you guys.
Yeah, man. Let me put in these earbuds
just to make sure. And this time, what's
that? And this time, oh no. And this
time from Seore.
Yeah, man. Uh, our guest
traveler, man. He is all over the place.
doing that research. So, for anybody
that might be completely oblivious to
this, uh, stumbling upon this, what
exactly is NR,
New Apostolic Reformation? Because I've
heard those terms, but I don't really
know exactly what it means. Um, it's is
it like a denomination? Is it something
totally different? What is it? No. Yeah,
that that's what everybody is is asking.
And if you ask people like hey where's
the headquarters? So there is no
headquarters. So basically what what it
is it's a it's a a loose organization.
Uh so and even you cannot even call it
an organization. It's kind of a
movement. Uh it doesn't have a
headquarters. It doesn't have a
denomination. It's across
denominations
basically and it has roots. Right. So uh
but but yeah the the whole the whole
idea is uh uh the seven mountain mandate
uh bringing you know uh uh usher in
God's kingdom here on earth kingdom now
uh these terms you might have heard
uh like uh or so is this more like an
ecumenical movement then also yeah it is
ecu ecumenical um uh by nature uh
because if everybody is going to be
Christianized it's postmillennialism
uh and even premillennialist uh uh like
like those disp dispensationalists can
be u um hooked into it because they
believe you know in the whole idea of
Israel being the end times uh uh uh
place where where where it's going to
kind of happen. Right. Right. So so
they're fascinated by the whole whole
idea and uh N is fascinated with Israel
for a different reason. Uh so what they
believe is they usher in God's kingdom
and they basically Christianize the
world through those seven pillars uh
education uh uh government, church and
you you name it. Uh and and with that
like they they basically Christianize
the whole world and then they bring the
world before Christ and say look we
Christianized it for you now you can
take it over. Is that what the Bible
tells us? No. It actually says that the
world's going to be in utter chaos
before Christ returns. But somehow
people have got in their head, I I've
heard even when I was growing up in the
Baptist churches and in the charismatic
churches, they said, "Oh, there's going
to be a great revival before the Lord
Lord returns." Um
I I think there's going to be a false
revival. I think there's going to be
people who are having their eyes open
because they're seeing the signs of the
times and there's going to be a lot of
people giving their hearts to Christ
because they're realizing, okay,
revelation's real. I'm seeing it happen.
But there's just as many people leaving
the church. It literally says in the
latter times, many will depart from the
faith, giving heed to seducing spirits
and doctrines of demons. So yeah, I
don't really think that the whole
world's going to come to Christ and then
Jesus then we can usher in Jesus and
yay, we're we're ready for you, Lord.
We're we're all set to go. Actually, you
know, the Bible talks about like
144,000.
That's not a big number. So, well, I
don't know where they can get this
stuff. And and that's the whole idea, a
false revival. And there's also in a new
age kind of like a revival that they're
they're pushing out. Um now so but but
the whole new apostolic reformation has
multiple organizations that are involved
right so there's one organization called
empowered 21 and across denominational
alliance again they all come together
Kumbaya um doctrine doesn't matter right
they all come together to to seek
revival now what they have as as their
vision or what their mission is is that
uh by 2033 3. Yes. By 2033 that everyone
on earth will have an encounter with
Jesus through the Holy Spirit. Oh wow.
Um
and I'm like you might have an encounter
but then it's too late.
Right. Oh man. I mean, if Christ,
but at the end of the day, if if uh if
if they think that everybody will have
an encounter with Christ, then then
that's not what my Bible says. It will
be a false Christ.
Yeah, for sure. Have you ever heard of a
guy named David Taylor?
Uh heard the name. They call him Apostle
David Taylor. And uh his whole ministry
is called Face to Face with Jesus. face
to face appearances from Jesus. And he
people that uh I I know someone
personally
um they say that, you know, they're
actually a part of this. They're it's
kind of like a mega church how you can
be a part of Kenneth Copeland's church
even if you're not where he's at or
whatever. And they say like everyone
should have a face-toface encounter with
Jesus. And I'm like what's the what's
the chapter and verse on that? Show me
that in the scripture. I need to see
that. Um
but yeah, well they might have one but
it's out of context
because his uh it looks like his church
is called Kingdom of God Global Church.
That's already in the name, right? So
that you can tell sometimes by the name
of the church uh what they're about and
not always but yeah. So it's very
interesting. Very interesting. This
assumes and what you're saying either
apostle or prophet or they um or um the
five-fold ministry is a is a is is one
uh that they like to use um pillow case
there's and and also they have multiple
names for it like Joel's army um or um
or the army you know the army of god and
and mil militaristic um taking over
yeah it's all about Yeah. Well, and
that's the thing. They're all heaven
tourists.
Yeah. Right. It's all about these dreams
and stuff, you know? I I'm not saying
that God can't give dreams. It's
happened in the Bible days and God's the
same yesterday, today, and forever. But
you just can't put all your faith in
these things. I I hear people that when
you tell them about what the truth about
what happens when you die and stuff like
that, people are like, "Nope, because
this person went to heaven, this person
went to hell, and this person rolled a
rode a roller coaster in heaven." I
mean, people put so much faith in
just the testimony of a person who says
they went somewhere when they don't even
line up. So, for one, correct? I've
heard I' I watched a long time ago I
watched a documentary about near-death
experiences and there was this woman who
was an atheist and she I think she was
like a doctor or something. She died and
she said when I was going up to the
light it was just the most amazing
overwhelming feeling of love I ever felt
in my life. And and I said does everyone
get to feel this? And the light said
yes. And I said even Hitler and the
light said yes. And she goes and then
she came back to her body and and
survived. And she said, "So now I'm I'm
just not afraid of death because
everyone gets to feel this. Everyone
gets to experience this when they die."
And it's like, so if you believe in
near-death experiences, you also have to
believe in her experience, which says,
even Hitler is going to go towards the
light and feel this. So you cannot put
your faith in near-death experiences. Uh
Satan has a million ways to deceive
people. And when you're doped up on
pharmaceuticals
in a hospital because you're on a
near-death experience or whatever,
there's no telling what kind of things
are. Satan has all kinds of doorways
open because this is drugs, drug usage.
You can go to another country and do
some iawasa, have the same experience.
You can smoke some DMT, have the same
experience. It's not of God. Do not fall
for these stories. We have to believe in
the Bible and the Bible alone because
the counterfeit is so cunning, so
crafty, so deceptive, so emotional that
you will fall for that garbage if you do
not know what the truth of the word of
God says. And that's the scary part. And
you well, you don't need drugs. I mean,
you you can you also I mean, you see in
those churches that the music, hypnotic
music, uh they they they drum up spirits
and it's not the Holy Spirit, you know.
Yeah. uh you get and and you can have
experiences all you want, but it doesn't
mean that it's the Holy Spirit. Amen.
Yeah. You know, you don't drugs don't
have to be involved. New age people's
are some of the most soberminded people.
Like they are sober, they're vegetarian,
and they're the healthiest people, but
they're, you know, meditating and
talking to ascended masters, including
Jesus.
Yeah. Jesus, Mary, Buddha, everybody.
Yep.
So yeah, so basically the the the new
apostolic reformation again it has no
location. It's uh it's it's basically uh
u and and there's a whole history that
we go through uh in a moment but uh
basically they have a similar belief
system uh what well that overlaps and
they choose unity over over doctrine uh
because they believe that you know that
they uh can usher in the big revival and
the revival is always around the corner.
They always you know it's the next big
thing. It's the next big thing, next big
thing, and it never happens. Yeah. And
and I believe some someday it will
happen, but it is a false revival. What
about that? Remember that thing that
happened in North Carolina or something
at a college? It was going on for like a
week. Yeah. Yeah. Aspbury revival. Yeah.
As one in line, one in line of many. I
mean, you got your Brownsville revival,
you had your Lakeland revival, you had
your Toronto blessing, you had your in
the '90s. So, there's so many different
different of those those uh those
revivals
uh basically uh that all come from the
same source. I want to touch on some of
those because this might be completely
new to some people, but when I grew up
in those Pentecostal movement churches,
I don't know if there's even Pentecostal
charismatic
um we were, you know, even our pastor
and everything was into Kenneth Copelan,
Jesse Dlanis, all those guys. Jesse
Delanis said he had a vision of going to
heaven like he went to heaven and all
this stuff. Um those those churches were
having this laughing drunk in the spirit
is what they call it. Being slain in the
spirit, drunk in the spirit, just
laughing their head off. And it was
looked at as like, oh, this is a this is
the Holy Spirit falling. This is a power
that's coming onto the church. But it
all came from Toronto, Canada. This what
was that guy's name? Do you remember the
laughing preacher is what they called
him? Um Oh, yeah. Rodney Howard Brown,
right? Rodney Howard Brown. Yeah. So,
who do those bark? Yeah. He was starting
to get connected with these pastors like
Kenneth Copelan and Jesse Dlanis and all
them. And he would come and he would
just touch somebody and they would start
and people thought this was the move of
God. This was when the condalini spirit
entered into the church. This happens in
yoga. people go to these uh you know go
to eastern mysticism places of the world
and they go to have this experience it's
called the condundalini and even when
you are in new age if you look up how to
have a condundalini experience there's
warnings
from the people who practice it there's
warnings on the page saying warning this
is a dangerous thing there's serpents on
the page because it's all about getting
that that uh serpent to go from your
base chakra which is down in your
genital region up your spine to your
brain the the crown chakra that's the
whole purpose of yoga is and meditation
and all this stuff is to get that
serpent to your brain that's Satan
wanting to have seat in the place that
only God should have it and when these
people have this condundolini effect
they go into these like uncontrollable
twitches is uh uncontrollable laughter.
We might have to show a little
sidebyside video, but I wanted you to
that's will be the next uh like h what
it is now. So today we really dive deep
into the history and we do see some
videos here and there, but that's more
kind of like the where it's all coming
from. But then the practices and the and
the and the here and now where you can
find it and you know we'll we'll get
into that another time. But uh yeah, we
definitely will do side by side even
speaking in tongues uh those kind of
things that that other other like like
occultists and newagers they speak in
the same gibberish as that the
charismatic church is doing as we speak.
So that's that's
we we do have a video on candid truth
about uh talking in tongues if you want
to check that out. all scripture. No,
no, just like personal opinion is coming
from the scriptures alone. We go into
what does it mean to speak with the
tongue of angels and all these things.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Real quick, I just I I
feel like there's some people here that
are just like this is completely new.
So, I just wanted to show a quick clip
of
this Holy Spirit thing. the yoga versus
see on the left here this is the
condundalini spirit God's amazing grace
I'll I'll turn the sound off but yeah
you see there's nothing different about
this spirit we have we must test every
spirit and when you see that there's
nothing different about these spirits um
that means it's the same spirit now
there's going to be people that say well
yeah but you know Satan always
counterfeits things of God. That's true.
What you're seeing on the left is the
counterfeit and what you're seeing on
the right is also the counterfeit
because the truth of speaking in tongues
is speaking in an in a language. It's a
supernatural gift to speak a language
that you didn't know to somebody to get
a message to them to get like say you
get dropped off in a foreign land.
God wants you to share the gospel with
them. He doesn't want you to share
gibberish with them. That does not edify
anybody. The Bible says that. It says if
you're speaking in an unknown language,
stay silent or else you sound like a
barbarian. He wants you to speak in a
language that is able to convey the
gospel. Now, this stuff, there's
actually nothing in the Bible that ever
says, and Paul twitched with extreme
laughter and was drunk. There's nothing
nothing in the Bible that says we should
have this kind of experience at all.
Nope.
Nope. Uh and and it comes from a a
different source and that's not the not
the source of the Bible. That's not the
source of God. It's that strange fire.
Yep. Strange fire. So my my journey uh
kind of I've I've seen all these things.
I've seen the falling in this the
so-called spirit. And uh so I went to a
Pentecostal church uh the um the
uh Assemblies of God. That's where where
I was born into born and raised. Um and
you know it it wasn't as extreme as what
you saw on the screen, but it happened
like the whole falling thing and the
gibberish and it was a soft a softer
version of it, but it was still the same
source. Right. Oh yeah. Now, uh, when I
got married, I moved to the US from the
Netherlands and the Assemblies of God is
worldwide, right? So, um, so we went to
a church and that church was called
Substance. That was a seeker-driven
church, but uh, uh, substance was far
far far to be found. There was no
substance at all. And there's a common
denominator, and I'll get to that. So
then we wanted more substance. So we
went to um what was called um uh living
word. You would think
right living word that the Bible goes
opens up and they they spoke they opened
the Bible but they they twisted the
Bible and on the board of directors was
Kenneth Copeland and uh uh and uh
Kenneth Hagen Jr. Wow. Uh the prosperity
uh pimp if you will. Yeah. Uh and so
then we moved to Nashville and in
Nashville we went to a church called the
the belonging and that church um I found
out that uh that one of the highest uh
um uh apostles and prophets in the
movement in the movement of the NR was
in that church and was le leading or or
over um overseeing basically as the
prophet and and apostle that church and
he was just going to that church. So, I
was I was shocked. Then I went back to,
you know, I've did I've done research
and all the churches that I've went I've
I've been to, they all were part of the
N and I was like, how is it possible
that a Pentecostal and then a secret
driven and then a word of faith and then
uh the church in Nashville was connected
with the planet shakers? that's more
kind of like Hillsong between Hillsong
and Bethl. Uh, and how is it that all
these people are all connected? So, I I
dig deeper and dig deeper and that's
where kind of the roots are coming from.
And not only myself, I I know quite a
few researchers as well and we get some
to hear some of them as well, some of my
friends uh some of their videos. But um
it's it's it's basically a whole
spiderweb. And at the end of the day, as
we discussed earlier on uh before the
show, uh all roads lead to wrong. Yep.
Every time, man. Yeah.
So, it's uh it's it's bizarre. So, where
where does it come from? And and it and
it if you go all the way back to to to
even to the na this nation being formed,
you had the Puritans, right? And the
Puritans,
they fled the Catholic Church and they
they want want the pure doctrine, right?
They wanted solar scriptura. However, um
I don't know of all of them, but I know
some of them, a group of them, uh they
uh went so far that um kind of the same
way. If you want if you wanted to um uh
if you wanted uh to to have uh meaning
in in in that in that area, you needed
to be part of church. You have to go to
church. That's the same thing that Rome
did, right? So basically they basically
did the same thing like dominionists
kind of like a dominionist mindset. Uh
so it's not new. It has been infiltrated
all over and over and over again. And so
the new apostolic reformation uh if
we're talking about uh as far as we're
going today as far as uh uh Alexander
Dowi John Alexander Dowi and maybe we
can uh show the the screen. Okay.
You want me to go to the next? So go to
the next slide. Next slide. Uh I'll go
over the seven mountains. So everybody
might be familiar with with the seven
mountains. So what they believe is that
they have to take over seven mountains
or seven spheres of culture, seven
spheres of influence. If you hear all
these these talks that is all the same
and it's the seven mountain mandate, the
arts and entertainment uh family,
business, government, education, media,
and religion.
That's very interesting because uh the
Catholic Church uh is sitting on what?
Seven hills the Bible says in
Revelation. It's crazy. Oh, interesting.
There's another there's a book written
by one of those leaders and it's and
it's called Invading Babylon.
And I'm like, okay, if you invade
Babylon, you basically take over
Babylon. You become Babylon. Yeah. So,
okay. And if Christ comes back, then
which side are you on? Yeah. He's coming
to set up his kingdom in Babylon.
So there you already have have and and
basically this this seven mountain uh
mandate or seven mountains of culture,
seven amount of spheres of influence. Uh
the there are two or basically three
people that came up with they had a
dream they said. There you go with
dreams and visions again. They had a
dream. One was uh Bill Bright from
Campus Crusade CRU.
Uh quite big, right? And then you have
um uh Lauren Cunningham who was from
Youth with a Mission. Both had the same
dream that uh God would usher in uh you
know uh revival and through all these
these uh these spheres of influence uh
arts, entertainment, family, business
and you name it. And they called one
another and they like oh we we had the
same dream and and let's let's discuss.
And then there was another guy called um
uh Francis Schaefer. He was more on the
reformed side. So there you got your
reformed uh uh angle because there you
have uh the guys called um
uh how do I explain that? Um
um reconstructionism,
a federal vision. So basically also
taking over the world postmillennialism
uh and they find ground with the new
apostolic reformation here and there as
well but they're in the reformed camp
which is not signs and wonders at all
but they still have that uh that that
mindset of taking over the the the world
for for Christ. Right? So that's their
angle, their their uh touching point
that they can work together on and set
aside all the differences in that way.
But anyway, Bill Bright and uh and also
um Lauren Cunningham, they teamed up
with uh Lance Wallnau and Lance Wallnau
took it to the whole new level and he
created the seven mountain mandate. So
that's where the seven mountain mandate
is coming from. Um and um anyway
that that is that is one thing. Um one
second here. Dismiss. Something popped
up on my screen. Um so but dominionism
is not new. Uh let's go back all the way
to the roots. Uh if you go to the next
slide
uh let's go to the pre- Pentecostal
roots because it comes out of the
Pentecostal uh Pentecostal roots. So
next slide uh there you see uh John
Alexander Dowi. Now he was a very
strange fellow. H a very interesting
fellow and he basically created uh a
city in uh in Illinois called Zion City
and he thought that he was the new
Elijah. That's you know the the prophecy
that Elijah would would come right
out of context of course but he was the
the Elijah. So he thought that he was
Elijah. He created basically the uh he
was you know the healings and that's
that that's how far goes back to he was
born in 1847 right so in that time frame
a lot of those uh th those those guys uh
rose up also in the new age and guys
like this with mixture of of new age and
uh new age thought and if you you see
there in 1896 Dawi disan disbanded the
International Divine Healing Association
to form the Christian Catholic Church in
Zion.
Very interesting. And Christian, he
named it the Christian Catholic
Apostolic Church. Apostolic. Oh,
interesting.
Very interesting. So uh so but it
doesn't um it doesn't um
the problem with these these these guys
that are so uh um
um they're very um top down, right? So
very uh how do you call it? Um uh
dictatorship, not or very uh very much
like the the leadership
tyrannical. Um and it it never goes
without abuse uh and and and kind of uh
other kind of things uh what you see in
the church right now. Right. So true.
Uh he had a lot of misconduct uh like a
lot of um financial issues. He he made a
lot of money out of it. Um uh that's
that's one thing. But he ruined a lot of
lives. He some he had like court dates.
so many court dates. Uh it's it's uh
insane. Uh but anyway, so so if the
roots already is wrong, right, then then
the fruit cannot be cannot be good. Um
and
so it's very interesting that from this
guy uh if you go to the next slide well
oh there's an interesting question here.
Somebody said he established one second.
He established a theoccratic political
and economic structure. That's what I
the word what I I was looking for. So
theocratic. So that was his his that
needs to be ruled on a theocratic way.
What's the question? Somebody asked uh
isn't the seven mountain mandate in the
project 2025 document that Trump's
cabinet is using. Is that true? Um
maybe not the wording, but yes. Okay.
Okay. the the idea the idea is the
national Christian nationalism and
theocratic what you read here the the
theocratic political and economic
structure but then also blended with
with with Christianity right so that's
the Christian nationalism and that's
also the seven mountain mandate taking
over the world and Christianize it so
there's there's there a different name
but you know different animal but at the
end of the day it's all the same so
there's kind of the political side which
is the Christian nationalism those are
the patriots and all that stuff and then
there's the N which is just we're like
the Christian side the religious side
and the political side are both doing
this they're both bringing we want we
want to make religious government right
huh one pillar is government right so
one one pillar is already government out
of government right there in the middle
yeah so basically
Paula White is and Lance Wallno they are
the political uh arm and and and so so
and then you have the church arm uh so
there are different they call it like uh
uh and the business is called uh the the
marketplace apostles and you know can
you can you name any apostle in the last
2,000 years?
No, I can't. No,
no, because there wasn't any. Right. And
and isn't it isn't it funny that the
Bible says in the last days false
apostles will come on the scene, right?
And every everybody is like uh welcoming
them welcoming them in. I'm like really?
Yeah. Like the Bible is so clear. They
they may argue, well, if it says false
prophets, then there must be like real
ones, too. Or else he would have just
said, you know, ignore all prophets. But
you still have to test them. And we are
testing them. And they're not measuring
up. They're not lining up biblically.
Not at all. Except that they are lining
up with what Revelation calls the
Antichrist beast system. They are lining
up with that. Yeah. aligning in
scripture with one or one uh one. Yeah.
Yeah. So um so then uh he also had his
publishing house uh called sign
publishing etc etc. So that's uh you're
on the next next slide already right or
no I didn't go here's the next slide
though. Okay. So basically you see here
um uh here he believed in an end times
restoration or spiritual gifts and
apostolic offices the church. So there
you go again, right? So uh uh in 19 1899
he declared himself God's messenger and
in 1909 1901 I mean he proclaimed to be
the spiritual return of the Hebrew
biblical prophet Elijah styling himself
as Elijah the restorer and the third
Elijah.
Wow. Very interesting.
Yeah. You must have a god complex if if
you you know if you if you call yourself
that way. Yeah.
So, and and that's the belief that
people have that in the last days
there's going to be two witnesses,
right? And they say it's going to be
Enoch and Elijah.
Yeah. Or Moses and Elijah. They have
different figures that they Yeah. that
they're talking about. But Yeah. Yeah.
And see, this is why it's so important
to understand Bible prophecy. It says
that those who have the the testimony of
Jesus Christ and the spirit of prophecy,
we have to we have to have the testimony
that we have a a faith in Jesus Christ,
that we have a a salvation testimony and
understand prophecy or else we're going
to be all mixed up because the end of
times deception is a salvation issue. If
you fall for the antichrist system, if
you take the mark of the beast, which is
a false system of religion, that is a
salvation issue. It you take the mark.
You're not sealed by God. You're taking
the mark. So, it's so important to
understand Bible prophecy, including all
these details about like the two
witnesses and
um yeah, everything. What where is the
millennial kingdom? Is it in heaven? Is
it on earth? What's going, you know, are
we supposed to be preparing earth to
have a a perfect people or everyone's a
Christian so that Jesus can set up? It's
so man that Satan has done an amazing
job at distorting everything about
prophecy and feeding it to the Christian
church to to where it's like, well,
you're not even going to be here for all
that. You're getting raptured out of
here. And uh when Jesus comes, he's
going to have this perfect kingdom earth
for a thousand years. And
man, it's amazing. It's interesting. And
you know, also uh he Dowi was was
basically a forerunner uh of
Pentecostalism
and many of his followers became
influential figures in the early 20th
century revival. There you go. There you
go again. Revival, right? Revival. Yeah.
So that's that that back all the way
back to 1847
where he was born and of course after uh
in the early 1900s um there there you
got your revival. So if you go to the
next slide
you see Charles Fox Pum and uh so that's
the next generation. So it goes from one
generation to the next generation.
Right? So you have first you have your
your John John Alexander Dowi and
Charles Fox Parmam he visited the the
the the movement right so so basically
uh his apostolic faith movement merged
with other Pentecostal groups and it's
very interesting that uh that this guy
Charles Foxparum
uh uh in 1914 uh to form the general
council of the assemblies of god in the
United States of America which is the
largest Pentecostal church right now.
Wow. This is very very interesting. But
Parham visited Zion and he uh he was
taught by John Alexander Dowi, right? He
was um mentored by John Alexander Dowi.
So you got so you got a uh uh basically
the next generation that is that is
pushing out the same the same ideas um
in into uh into the the the church.
Man, the 1800s were a strange time. You
know, that's where a lot of the
spiritualism came back in. The the Fox
sisters and the rappings and the I mean,
a lot that spiritualism was coming back
hard and there's a lot of deception
going on back then. I didn't even know
about this stuff.
Yeah, this is the same era, right? So
it's uh and it's and and these things uh
h have a link with new age and we'll see
that later on in the presentation that
there's a lot of new age uh is is
interwoven in this whole idea and this
whole system. Um so very interesting. So
if you go then to the next slide uh next
slide is the Isuza Street revival. So I
missed that one. Uh so we talked about
Brownsville and all these but this one
was very key because all the Pentecostal
movements will point to the Zusa Street
revival. That's when Pentecostal
Pentecostalism was born. Interesting. So
1906. So if you go to the next slide,
you have Williams Joseph Seymour.
Now Seymour was in LA. He was in in in
uh and he was you see here Sema's work
in Los Angeles would eventually develop
into the Isuza Street Revival which is
considered by many as the birthplace of
the Pentecostal movement. Now his mentor
kind of was um
uh what's his name? Charles Charles Fox
Parm that we discussed before and Parm
has the link to John Alexander Dowi
again right so it's go go goes from one
to the other to the other uh John G Lake
is another healing revivalist uh that
has that comes out of this whole
movement now um back backing up Charles
Fox Parham
um we talked about speaking in tongues
right
so Charles Fox Pam is the one who
reinstated the speaking in tonesues
version. For 2,000 years, nobody spoke
in tonesues anymore. It faded away.
Yeah. And and and so he was the one that
basically reinstated speaking in
tonesues because everybody needs to
speak in tonesues according to him. And
first they thought it was an actual
language. Now then what they did was
they sent people out to because there
was a lady um uh uh Agnes Osman or
something like that and she wrote down
something that looks like looked like
Chinese but it was kind of like a
scratching on the paper. Um so she they
sent people out to China and to other
places but they came back delusioned
delusional or or how you call it and um
basically it didn't work. So what they
did was okay well if it's not an an
intelligent language then it must be a
heavenly language. That's where the
whole idea comes from. Wow dude so they
have they have to find an excuse but
instead of going back to the Bible oh
are we wrong? No they have the
experience
and out of experience well it must be
God. So we need to find an explanation
and then we twist God's word for it.
Right? So that's how they twisted the
whole that whole thing. So back to
William Seymour, he started that whole
Isuza Street revival and that's where
the birth of all the Pentecostal
movements are coming out of like the
church of God um and we just spoke about
the
um the Assemblies of God uh and you name
it. So all the Pentecostals are coming
out of this whole movement of the street
revival.
It's interesting.
Interesting. I I want to show something
here just to
prove this point because I know there's
people that just they're they're so into
this. I mean, even my family and
everything, they're so into this that
they can't believe that this is not of
God. And uh so I want to share this
screen real quick.
So, all right. So if you look up light
language, it's called star language,
dragon language. Ironically, if you look
up light language, you will see people
who are giving literal
prophetic messages. Notice right here,
it says dragon, light language, uh song
message, light language, um portal, holy
fire. Look, these are words that you
hear in the church. Holy fire. Now
listen to what's going on here.
Uh hope it'll play with audio.
[Music]
Let me tell you, she's not a Christian.
She's not a Christian, people. This is
um Look, it says update, DNA upgrade.
Like, these people are going to upgrade
their DNA. Wait till this uh I made a
video where I showed some of this stuff
compared to what's happening in the
church.
Wow, she's burping her. Oh my goodness.
What is
I've heard this in church.
Yeah. Yeah. Same thing. And they all are
like this crazy. And when you look at
the the comments, look at this. It says,
let me blow it up. Holy feel exhausted
now and burping today. Maybe that's No,
this isn't her. This is She liked it.
Holy feel exhausted now and burped
today. You're right. Heavy energy
lately. I've been up. Uh, wow. So much
power in this video. I had goosebumps
running from my ankles up and down my
spine. You cannot trust goosebumps in
church and say it must have been of God.
It felt so good. Look, amazing work. I
felt it when you were sending out
rainbow energy. You are amazing. Much
love. Like dude, this is just look.
Thank you and blessings to you. You
cannot fall for this garbage just
because it feels good. You feel
goosebumps. You feel blessed. This is
new age stuff. The condundalini, the the
shaking around, all that stuff. And the
speaking in gibberish is not biblical.
It's not of God. This is straight
demonic.
Yep. Absolutely. Well, and isn't it
ironic if you go back to the to the
slide to the to the next slide, uh
Charles Fox, he was baptized as a child
at the church of of the assumption in
Franklin, a Catholic parish,
Catholic, all read of all all roads lead
to Rome. Roman Catholic.
And when Seymour was 14 years old, his
parents built a house about a mile and a
half from his birthplace at I don't know
that word, adjacent adjacent uh to the
New Providence Baptist Church in
Centerville that the family likely
attended while remaining Catholics.
Wow. There there's your infiltration
again, right? Yeah. So, this false false
fire uh is coming from the Catholic
Church. You saw Alexander Dowi. You see
this guy again from Catholic into into
the the the the the into Pentecostal
into basically infiltrating
the the Protestant movements. Wow. We've
mentioned false fire uh things like
that. In the book of Revelation, it
talks about how the antichrist will have
power to bring fire down from heaven.
Now, that could very well be physical. I
don't discredit that. But the book of
Revelation is a very symbolic book. A
woman is a church, right? And a beast is
a kingdom and seven heads or seven
mountains, all this stuff. It could very
well be that the antichrist who brings
in this one world false religion is
going to bring down a false holy spirit
because the holy spirit is represented
by fire in the Bible. The gift of or the
the fire, this flaming tongue of fire.
Now you have a beast which has power to
bring down fire from heaven onto the
earth that will deceive
many. Right. I think there is a
connection there.
Yeah. Yep. Yep. And think about
Pentecost, right? Pentecostals.
Pentecost, the fire that came from
heaven, right? The the the the flames.
That's right. So it it's not uncommon,
right? So Satan always has a
counterfeit.
Yeah. So then you see here by the end of
1906 most leaders from Isuza Street h uh
had spun off to form other congregations
such as the apostolic faith church.
Again you get your apostolic right. So
it's uh uh and then you have the church
of God in Christ the Pentecostal
holiness movement. Uh
uh so yeah there's a the one
Pentecostals uh Pentecostal assemblies
of the world. So there's a lot of
churches that came out of this whole
whole movement. Wow. Including uh the
Assemblies of God. If you go to the next
page, uh so Fred Francis, so FF Bosworth
and Assemblies of God. Well, you see
there in blue highlighted several years
after his healing, he attended Alexander
Dowi's church in Zion City. Again, he
also went there, right? Dowi again. then
joined the Pentecostal movement and
attended Pentecostal services. And he uh
and if you see the next highlighted one
here, he was one of the founders of the
Assemblies of God. So it goes all the
way back to Alexander Dowi. And if you
go to the headquarters of the Assemblies
of God, you see Alexander Dowi with a
with his, you know, like a like with a
honored in the Hall of Fame. Really? M.
So it's And he he was he was a criminal.
He was a criminal.
Oh yeah. He he he was a criminal. He was
accused of all kinds of of stuff. That's
what happens with all these cults, these
false churches. It always ends up being
um sexual abuse and often murder and
things like that.
Yeah. with uh with uh with demonic uh or
with healings uh and and uh like false
healings and uh um I think it was like
demon possessions uh you know uh
basically he they killed some people as
well because of that or it was had to do
with healing and and uh the medicine the
whole med medical thing like denying uh
so they couldn't have access to any
medication
uh
that kind of stuff. So they went to
extremes in that as well and people
died. So he he got accused of things
like that. It's like bizarre.
That's not FF Bosworth. That is
Alexander Dawi that we're talking about.
But that is the example of all these
people, right? Yeah.
Uh FF Bosworth also uh was the P piano
player uh in in the worship uh there at
Design City. Uh so at um Alexander Ga's
church or his city man unbelievable.
So from there you get your your your
Assemblies of God which is now the
biggest the biggest Pentecostal church.
Uh if you go to the next slide uh so
that's the charismatic renewal. So you
have your Pentecostals right and now and
it always has to progress right it also
always have to progress to worse and
worse and worse. Yeah. So now you got
your charismatic renewal and shephering.
So shephering is is the forerunner of
the the
uh latter rain movement and it's not the
latter rain that the Bible talks about
but it is I mean but the false false
revival idea. Um and then from the
letter rain movement comes the N but
let's stick here the the charismatic
renewal is first and then you got your
shephering. Uh so let's go to the next
slide.
So here you get your charismatic
movement. So now William Brandham comes
into into play and Oral Roberts. Now
Oral Roberts is more known than William
Brennham. Yeah, I've heard it. Um yeah,
Oral Roberts basically is is the one
that is uh that that kind of spin is the
grandfather of the uh with Kenneth Hagen
kind of like the grandfathers of the the
word of faith movement and the
prosperity movement. And then William
Brennham is is kind of the the the one
that that ignited kind of the the the
ne but the the the the
lettering movement basically.
So first if you if you look at the the
highlighted uh the highlighted one the
revivalists of the time including
William Brennham Oral Roberts and AA
Allen held large in the in
interdenominational there you have your
ecumenical meetings again right meetings
which emphasized the gifts of the spirit
not coming to Christ right not not uh
not salvation but yeah repentance no the
gifts of the spirit. Uh this global
revival led to greater awareness and
acceptance of Pentecostal teachings and
practices. So Oral Roberts and William
Brham are uh they had like like a a
magazine called the force of healing uh
and a lot of people uh were involved in
in um uh in this movement. And you would
think like you know a Joel Ostein and
we'll come to that in a moment. Joel
Ostein. Oh, but he's he's such a kind
person and he's not so charismatic.
Yeah, but his dad was involved in this
whole thing. And we'll we'll have
evidence in a moment. So, it's insane.
So, all the all these these groups are
are are splintering off and you get all
these different splinter groups, right?
So, uh but William Brham is a very
interesting guy. Um and they basically
uh and and that spinned off into the
third wave in the 1980s. You got your uh
charismatic renewal or the 60s actually
uh it started in in the 60s and then in
the in the 80s uh you got your um your
third wave basically. So first you got
your um uh charismatic uh the
charismatic movement started in the in
the 70s 60s7s together with Roman
Catholics with the
charismatics because they spoke in
tongues as well. That's interesting.
Based on experience, you come together.
Yeah. And and
uh it all went to the 80s and that's
where you got got your third wave and
that's where the N basically got spun
off. I never really knew that Roman
Catholics were into like the tongues and
stuff, but we keep seeing the connection
all throughout here. Yep. Yeah. They
have a whole cashmack renewal uh
movement basically. Well, the thing
about Catholicism is
you can be of any faith and be a
Catholic. I mean, I've I've seen the
pope literally have a commercial that
said, "All faiths, we all serve love. We
all worship love." Um, so they show a
Buddhist and a Muslim and a Jew and a
Christian all come together and they
say, "We all serve the same God." And
right before the pope died, he said all
religions are a path to God. They're
like different languages to God. So he's
saying if you're a Hindu or a Buddhist
or a Muslim or whatever, and you have a
desire to know God, and you do it
through these other avenues, these other
religions, well, you're just it's just
another way to God. It's another
language to God. Like God's this
multicultural being that just has many
ways. But Jesus said, "I am the way, the
truth." There's only one, not a way. I'm
one of many ways. He didn't say anything
kind of ambiguous like that. He said,
"I'm the way. No man comes to the father
except through me." No Buddha, no
Muhammad, no none of that. And but yet
that's what the Catholics teach. So they
have um you know the pope would have
these big ecumenical religious I don't
know what you even call them ceremonies
where religious leaders from every
different religion in the world would
come and perform in front of him and
give speeches and you know they'd all do
these entertaining things dancing and
and it was just like yeah we accept
every culture we're all beautiful
children of God and he And it was a big
push for this ecumenicism. So yeah,
speaking in tongues would probably be no
problem to Catholicism because oh it's
just another way to talk to God, right?
Yep. Correct. Correct. Uh so uh Oral
Roberts uh he is kind of like the as I
said the father of the the the um the
prosperity movement and the word of
faith. And if you go to the next slide,
you will see uh that you see Oral
Roberts and Kenneth Copeland. There's
the connection with Kenneth Copeland and
Kenneth Copeland. It's a video. Yeah, we
can watch it in a second.
Brother Copelan,
would you come and stand in my place?
[Applause]
Lori, would you come and stand in
Evan's, please?
Evan, would you come stand by me?
Now, brother Copen and your dear wife,
Gloria, would you look at us? Look on
us.
Silver and gold have we plenty.
Hallelujah.
Oh yes,
wow, dude. That just sounds so arrogant.
I mean, if you think about it, the the
scripture says like Peter or was Peter
and John or they said silver and gold,
but you have not, right? Uh in Jesus
name, uh uh stand up or whatever. M but
they just turn it flip flip it upside
down and they they're just boasting in
the you know in their gold and silver
they have plenty
that those are you know the prosperity
and and and word of faith preachers that
that's where it started. That's
literally like a antirist. That's what
Satanists do. They take the Bible they
flip it. They read it backwards. All
that stuff. I didn't even put that
together. That was a good catch because
I something about it sounded familiar. I
was like, "Is that in the Bible?" And
then I I forgot that they had said
because somebody was asking um I guess
they were asking for help and they said,
"Well, silver and gold, we we don't have
any, but we can pray for you or heal you
or something." So, it was more about
meeting your true spiritual needs, not
abundance of money. Because Jesus said
it's hard for a rich man to enter the
kingdom of heaven. He says u you know he
told the rich young ruler go and sell
everything you had. I'm not saying that
if you have money you have to get rid of
it but it is it become it can become a
hindrance in your life because when you
are so selfsufficient
you become less dependent upon God. I'll
tell you from experience that the
closest I've ever been become to God was
when I was in the hardest times of my
life. And I think I just talked to a
lady today. She said the same thing. You
know, she was going to her and her
husband and kids were going to church
every week and everything,
but she said I had no real relationship
with God. And she didn't know it. She
didn't even know it when she was going
to church every week. She felt like, you
know, I'm a Christian. I go to church
every week, but the rest of the week was
normal. And she got this huge growth. I
mean, like the size of a orange. It'd be
the size of a grapefruit, but she's
small. Um, and the doctors were saying
they had to they were going to have to
cut it and all this stuff and she got
closer to God than ever before and it
miraculously went away. God still
performs miracles. God hears prayers,
but he also allows things to happen in
our lives that will humble us, that will
cause us to be become dependent upon
him. And I'm thankful for the trials.
You know, it actually says in the Bible,
rejoice in tribulation and that he will
refine us through the fire. and Joseph
had to go through the pit before he got
to the palace. There's so many stories
about people having to reach rock bottom
and that's when they really get to have
a a close relationship with God and see
a miracle happen in their life. Well,
well, and and even if it doesn't come,
right, because if you look at all the
all the apostles Oh, yeah. they've been
killed. That's right. They didn't see
any prosperity, right? Their prosperity
comes when when when when Christ comes
back, right? for for his his his his
people. That's when when when we have
the promise the promises, right? The the
promise is not an earthly promise. I
mean, yes, God can bless us, but it
doesn't mean that uh he will. There's no
guarantee, right? So, yeah, they're
making a formula. Um we store up our
riches in heaven. Don't store up your
riches here because moth and rust decay
them. And that these people are saying,
"Oh, gold and silver, we have plenty."
Well, guess what? When the fire comes,
every element on earth is going to melt
along with your money. And you can't
take any of it with you. And what
profits a man to gain the whole world
and lose his very soul? Man, this is
disturbing. Yeah.
So, so, so that is Oral Roberts and then
Oral Roberts was connected with William
Brandon, right? So if that fruit is
rotten. So let's see what what this guy
is a researcher. So he he came out of
William Brennan Brennham's cult. Uh and
uh and he has excellent videos. But this
one will show you who William Brham
actually is. Okay.
When leaders of the New Apostolic
Reformation proclaim receiving the
mantle of William Brham or present their
ministries as extensions of the greater
movement that Brham grandfathered,
people attracted to those ministries are
often unaware of the deception. Not only
is this alleged mantle fiction, the
overall movement that Brham
grandfathered is also fiction. Like his
prototype, John Alexander Dowey, William
Brham advertised supernatural power to
heal that quote unquote never failed one
single time. While doing so, Brham
advertised claims of people being healed
while concealing examples of people who
remained sick and even died. Still
today, his cult following brags that
William Brham healed the young Donnie
Morton and uses Morton to recruit
members into the cult. Not only did
Morton die of the disease that brought
him and his father to the healer,
Morton's own family denounced William
Brham as a fraud. These outrageous
examples are fictional stories and you
can find them on our website, Staged
Healings. People claiming to have been
healed multiple times are documented.
Brham's claims to have raised people
from the dead in his hometown of
Jeffersonville were debunked by local
newspapers. Yet, this information never
made it to his crowds with itching ears.
You can learn this and more on
William-Brham.org.
Unbelievable.
And you see that today as well, right?
The same thing. It's the same trick.
Yep. Oh, yeah. Vinnie Hen and all that
stuff. They I have a documentary called
uh Suffer the Children is what the
documentary is called if you guys want
to watch it. But they
they expose these guys. Uh Kenneth
Copelan, Jesse Dlanis, Benny Hinn, and
all that. And like there was a kid that
went up on stage with Benny Hinn and he
couldn't see and he was saying I'm
starting I'm I think I'm starting to see
and all this stuff. Everybody's clapping
all that stuff. But they interviewed him
later and he said well you know it was
just kind of exciting and I you know I
could see a little better or whatever
but I'm still blind. You know, it's like
the sensationalism is building it up to
where people think that something is a
real healing. But when you check back on
the people, you know, there maybe
somebody has a backachche and there the
excitement, the applause and your
adrenaline's going, you're like, "Yeah."
And you, you know, you you stand up
straight and you jump around and all
this stuff. And the next day you're like
bedridden because you shouldn't have
done that to your back and it was just
all excitement.
Yeah. Yeah. It's a adrenaline, right?
Rush of adrenaline. And and secondly, it
can also be that Satan inflicts
something, right? And then he takes it
away to lur lure you into the movement.
That's right. So then, oh, you're
healed. Well, actually, you're you were
not sick in the first place, but uh it's
just tricked by Satan. And if you if
you're one of those people out there
that find that hard to believe, like,
well, well, Jesus said a kingdom divided
against itself, and you know, Satan
comes to steal, kill, and destroy. Like,
he how could he heal? Um, think about
those newagers who are doing Reiki
healings, crystal healing, you know,
sage and all this stuff. Those things
are doing something. There wouldn't be a
whole industry, acupuncture, and all
that stuff. There wouldn't be a whole
industry if it didn't work. It's
working, but it's working by a false
spirit because Satan wants to deceive
people into his cult to believe that
yes, your the power is in crystals, not
God. The power is in sage and Reiki and
all that stuff. And so, yeah, when you
are dabbling in the occult or you're not
walking with Christ, Satan can put an
ailment on you and it could be a
lifelong ailment, but then he can remove
it to make you feel like that that
healing worked. Think about the kid that
was in the Bible. The man brought his
grown son to Jesus and said, "He's had
this his whole life. He He nashes his
teeth. He throws himself in the fire.
throws himself in the water, all this
stuff. And Jesus said to the demon,
"Come out of him." Wait a minute. So
this kid was suffering with a demonic
possession, with a demonic spirit that
was afflicting him his whole life from
childhood. Therefore, Satan can afflict
people. I mean, look at the story of
Job. Because of Satan, he afflicted Job
with soores all over his body. So, Satan
can afflict you with disease and
ailments and things like that. And if he
wants to, he can remove that, right?
Because if a demon came out of that boy
that was having epilepsy or whatever,
then it looks like a healing. That's
going to happen more and more in these
last days as Satan starts ramping up his
deception. Yeah. Yep. So, now that's
William Brennan, right? The deceiver.
Uh, and and I mean, he believed in the
serpent seed. uh doctrine. Uh I mean he
had a lot of weird doctrines but he is
the father basically of the of the new
apostolic reformation or the
grandfather. So let's go to the next
slide the next video. There you see
current leaders like
you will see them u um Bill Johnson and
some others uh from churches across the
nation and movements in the NR that
honor William Brennan. Let's watch this.
[Music]
Here's
what I'm believing for.
I know it's never happened,
but I know that it must before the end.
There must be not just individuals. I'm
thankful we have individuals that are
rising up with such anointing, such
strength. We have people scattered all
over the planet right now that are just
making a mess of things in all the right
ways. We're so encouraged.
But what I'm believing for is a
generation, a generation will rise up
with a corporate faith, a corporate
anointing to press into realms because
it's my conviction that as much as God
put on a William Brham or a Katherryn
Khman or a Wigglesworth, he'll put far
greater anointing on a company of people
than he ever would on an individual. And
to do that there must be that corporate
sense of we have to deal with the issue
of obeying the rules of this kingdom to
tap into the resources of this kingdom.
John G. Lake in healing and miracles.
It's because of the divine power of the
Holy Ghost and his grip on dominion and
his grip. And I'm not just talking about
him. I'm talking about many men and
women in the past. William Brandham had
a gift of a word of knowledge that was
so scary. It was so scary. He would know
exactly who the person was in the back
of the crowd, what city they came from,
what car they drove, what their
neighbor's house looked like. This is
crazy. And people were like, and it
gripped men's hearts. It gripped women's
hearts with such a ferociousness that
there was no way to escape the love of
God.
Several years ago, I was laying on the
floor um I think it may have been in a
prayer chapel, but and it's asking God
if I could have the mantle of William
Brandham. I just got done, in fact, Bill
has a a series video, old videos of
William Brham. I just watched one of
them where he called out about 40 people
in a row and he said, "Your your name is
like John and your doctor's name is Dr.
you know, Henry and you got uh cancer of
whatever and and uh your sister Mary
told you to come here and did that to
with about 30 or 40 people on this
video. So, I got done watching that
video. I'm like, "Oh my goodness, I
don't even have a prophetic gift." And
so, I was in a prayer chapel laying on
the floor and I said, "God, would you
give me the mantle of William Brandham?"
And he said, "Well, how could I do that?
If I did that, it would it would destroy
you." And I was laying there. It was
like the Lord asked, "How could I do
that?" I So then I said I waited about a
few minutes and I was thinking about it.
I said, "Well, you could put the same
mantle on a whole generation. Then we
wouldn't stand out
from one another." He said, "All right,
I'll do that."
Isn't that awesome? That's what the Lord
wants to do.
And so what God wants to do with a gift,
with the word of knowledge, with the
prophetic word is he wants to be so
accurate that it reveals the secrets of
men's hearts so that they cannot resist
God and they have to give up. They have
to surrender. I
That's what I was thinking.
Exactly.
[Music]
Wow, dude. That's exactly what I was
thinking when they were saying that. I
was thinking
fortune tellers do that. You can turn on
Oprah Winfrey or Kelly Clarkson or
whatever and they'll have some medium on
there and he'll point out to you, uh,
your grandma, her name was Sarah, right?
And uh she had a little a rose that she
gave you, right? And all this stuff. I
mean, demons can whisper in these
people's ears. Divers. These are
divination. Well, and and and even even
besides that, uh what they what they did
also was filling in prayer cards, right?
Oh, that's true. All the information is
and and these gullible people, these
guys wear
earpieces. Some popoff was the one that
was uh was uh discovered, right? All of
a sudden they heard on the micro micro
on the on the speakers somebody talking
to him was the wrong the wrong button
that they push. No way. Oh yeah, he he
got caught. I didn't hear about that. Uh
I mean it's crazy that you know with all
the information so they can just read it
read it off p and memorize it and wow oh
there's a guy named John and right and
and oh you got this and this like now
you have Sean Bolts it's also a prophet
in the movement n he's called the goo
the Google prophet so he he looks he
looks on his tablet right and he says
yeah as if He wrote it all down, but
he's looking at a Facebook profile. It's
just open and uh and the same guy
actually that created this last video.
He created the video about about Sean
Boltz exposing him that he's just uh and
and then later on he goes to the
Facebook profile and sees exactly all
the information that that Sean Boltz
just mentioned in that TV program or or
revival meeting, whatever. So, it's
insane how they just lie to you. That
would be Yeah. I mean, you could that'd
be so easy to do. You have a tablet. You
think, "Oh, the pastor's just reading
sermon notes and he's sitting there
searching somebody's name on Facebook
and you probably got like a a GoFundMe
for your surgery." And he's like, "Yeah,
there's a John here. You got uh you have
cancer. You just found out." And like,
"How'd you know?" Wow, dude. The
deception. And and so so and that's
William Brandon that they're talking
about, right? the the heretic and the
guy the false teacher uh with the false
anointing. Right? Now, if you go
further, if you go to the next the next
video,
look who the pastor is of William Brham.
The Pentecostal sect that Roy Davis
founded and that William Brham recruited
for was created to hold membership
drives for the Knights of the Flaming
Sword, a white supremacy group created
by Roy E. Davis, the official
spokesperson for the Ku Klux Clan, and
William Joseph Simmons, the founder of
the 1915 Kux Clan. While working with
one Dr. John Roach Stratton. Stratton
and Davis were working to create a
supreme kingdom of white supremacy
through fundamentalist religion. Davis
used his position in the clan to promote
both the KKK, his sect of white
supremacy, and his cult group, which
combined the three. Stratton's
connections to white supremacy and his
views on race and relationships with
African-Americans were exposed in 1927.
However, during which time he attempted
to distance himself from the Supreme
Kingdom before being exposed, however,
Davis and Klux Clan founder William
Joseph Simmons began building the new
white supremacy organization, the
Knights of the Flaming Sword. You can
learn this and more on William-Brum.org.
What? Chattanooga, that hits close to
home right there, bro. I know. I know.
And And isn't that crazy that they want
that that anointing? Really? That's what
they're asking for that mantle, right?
They they want that that mantle. He was
so he was so spiritual and blessed,
right? But he is uh working with the
KKK. Really? Whoa, bro. This is sick.
And that's the grandfather of the new
Apostolic Reformation.
Wow. And it go it goes it goes wilder.
Have you ever heard Have you ever heard
of the name Jim Jones? Oh yeah, I know
about Jim Jones.
Yeah, it was if we talk about you drink
the Kool-Aid referring to Yeah. So Jim
basically uh Yeah, he was leader. Go
ahead. Yeah. Yeah. He was a cult leader
and basically uh he he had such a
following and basically he he killed his
the whole village Jonestown uh with
Kool-Aid or whatever it was. Um uh so so
basically um they were so um yeah I
don't know that's that's that's how why
you cannot ever
uh follow like man right and and and and
uh again it's it's a uh um theocratic
it's really uh top-down uh uh leadership
and and not servant leadership right
it's it's really top- down leadership
and uh um uh authoritative or how you
said it like really um um he's the
leader and you cannot go against the
leader right don't touch the eyeapple of
God or don't touch the anointed of God
right that's what they say no question
no question and so
Jim Jones now go to the next video of
the next slide and we'll see what the
connection is with Jim Jones and William
Brandon we have some very exciting and
interesting research currently being
published to William Brandham Historical
Research. It was formerly believed that
Jim Jones needed William Brandham to
kickstart his career at the Kal
Tabernacle in 1956. As it turns out,
William Brham needed Jones to salvage
his. Jones was quickly turning into a
key figure in the message. And if not
for a scandal involving Brham at an
event hosted by Jones in 1957, Jim Jones
would have likely become one of Brham's
campaign managers. We've added a new
research section entitled The
Brotherhood Healing Crusade, the name
that Jim Jones gave the first in the
series of conventions that boasted
William Brham as the main speaker. Check
it out on William Brham Historical
Research.
Uh,
and that mantle is that they want,
right? That mantle that he worked for
Jim Jones, right? I mean, the the
murderer. I mean, he made hundreds,
possibly more people die.
Yeah. Wow, dude. Yeah. I heard Jim Jones
would have uh stigmata, like he would
bleed in his palms and stuff. And and
this is why you can't believe in signs
and wonders. There's actually nothing in
the Bible that says anything about
stigmata. That's actually a some kind of
Catholic
uh superstition or something. But yeah,
there Satan has the power to do lying
signs and wonders, miracles. I mean,
Revelation talks about miracle working
demons um in the last days. And so you
cannot you cannot base truth on
emotions, signs, and miracles. You just
can't. I mean, there were hundreds of
thousands of people that were they saw
an apparition of what they thought was
Mary, but it was really just a glowing
disc flying around and they were they
were healed. I mean, people were hanging
up crutches in this cave and stuff. And
that was a Fatima, the thousands of
people that saw that.
Yeah. So, so
you cannot trust man, right? You cannot
you have to trust God's work above
anything else and research like how can
you ask for the mantle of of a guy that
is so deep into into weird stuff and
connections all over with KKK and Jim
Jones. I mean, and call that a hero in
the faith, a general in the faith. And
that is the the the the grandfather of a
movement that is not a movement of God
at all. And if you go to the next slide,
you'll see a connection with
Freemasonry.
According to Jack Harris, former
worshipful master of a Masonic lodge,
Freemasonry considers Jesus Christ to be
no greater than Moses, Elijah, Muhammad,
or Buddha. In some versions of his stage
persona, which use themes from his
manifest sons of God doctrine, William
Brham also considered Jesus to be
nothing more but a prophet. In those
versions of the stage persona, William
Brham misinterpreted John 5:19 to claim
that Jesus Christ was powerless unless
first having seen a vision and then
pariting what was seen in that vision.
Whether intentional or not, there are
several Masonic symbols, themes, and
numbers that are used in William Brham's
cult. When the Billy Brham Pentecostal
Tabernacle transitioned to Brham
Tabernacle, and a sign was hung above
the door with that name, a pentagram was
displayed on the front of the building.
The star was tilted slightly right, as
is done in the Masonic Order of the
Eastern Star. William Brham's sister
Dolores was also a member of the Eastern
Star and the pentagram suggests that
William Brham himself was also involved.
William Brham never openly admitted to
being a Freemason, but many of his
mentors, partners, and leaders of his
sect did. Masonic symbolism exists
throughout William Brham's extrabiblical
doctrines and religious propaganda,
especially in Brham's use of the
pyramids as religious symbolism. The
Great Pyramid of Giza with four
equilateral triangles carries great
significance in Freemasonry. And
according to Brham, the Great Pyramid
was a quote Bible written to replace
what he claimed to be the first Bible,
the Zodiac.
Oh wow, dude.
So KKK Freemasonry
uh Jim Jones Jim Jones and this is the
guy that lifting up, dude. This is sick.
And they want that mantle, right? I'm
like in the first place
mental grabbing and mental uh the only
God gives gives gifts, right? You cannot
have somebody else's mantle. happened
once with Elijah and Elisha, but that
you know because that happened then, you
know, oh but then then we all can do it.
No, that's not it's it's it's not a
prescription, right? Exactly. There's a
lot of things, you know, um there was a
prophet that was told to be naked and
lay on his side for a long time. I don't
ex Yeah. and eat sandwiches over burnt
dung or something. I mean, there's some
weird stuff. I'm not gonna try to do all
that, right? No, no, no. Exactly. Yeah.
Yeah. So, but but they want a man mantle
of this guy. Uh and that that is
basically the the your your
uh influence, right? And I'm like, if
that's your mentor, if that's all the
books that you that you read and all the
the the tapes that you that you see and
and all the teachings that you that you
that you adhere to, I'm like, huh, that
movement cannot be from God. Yeah.
So, I just mentioned Joel Ostein. If you
go to the next next video, you'll see
the connection with Joel Ostein.
What do Joel Olstein, Jim Jones, and
William Brham have in common? The
message. Joel's father, John Olstein,
was deeply involved with the full gospel
businessmen and the latter rain version
of William Brham's message that produced
numerous splinter groups such as Jim
Jones and People's Temple. When John's
ministry was suffering due to his latter
rain affiliation, Dema Shakarian stepped
in to help fund John Olstein and funded
his first tent revival. Ostein
frequented Life Tabernacle where Brham's
business entities were created. John was
a familiar face in Brham's healing
revival and was announced in the
meetings. William Brham referred to him
as brother Olstein from Texas. Joel
Olstein continues parts of the latter
rain message still today. You can find
this and more on William-Brrenham.org.
[Music]
Wow.
So
the plot thickens.
I know, right? So the connections
connecting the dots, right? So all all
these things are fall falling together.
I'm like, huh? I I knew there was a
connection everywhere, right? But where
does it all come from? Well, that that's
where it's coming from. So
insane. Insane. That is. So then after
the that was the latter rain as they
talked about, right? So the letter rain
movement that was the front the the the
the forerunner for the the N. So if you
go to the next slide, you have the
prophetic movement and the N.
And next slide uh is the Kansas City
prophets. So
in Kansas City there were the there was
a group called the Kansas City Prophets
and uh u uh here you see the the the
names like Paul Gain, Bob Jones, Bill
Haymon, Larry Randolph, James G. Uh
there are kind of like a lot of a lot of
people involved. Uh and they call
themselves the Kansas City Prophets. M
um uh and uh two of those Paul Kaine and
Bob Jones both had uh like uh I mean
uh alcohol abuse uh drunkenness. Uh Bob
Jones was also uh uh stripping people
naked and then prophesy over them. What?
Um yeah, crazy crazy stuff. He was a
pervert. And one of those two, Paul
Kaine or Bob Jones was also uh I believe
if not mistaken uh had something to do
with with um uh something with gay uh
stuff. So
if anybody if anybody considers himself
prophet, apostle, disciple like to me
those are like red flags. I don't know.
Yeah, I know. I know. Right.
Now, now the interesting thing is Mike
Bickl is from the the the the
organization IHOP, International House
of Prayer, not the Pancake Place. Uh but
but that fell apart recently. And you
know why? There was uh Mike Bickl was
accused of the same things like uh uh
inappropriate behavior and accusations
of of sexual misconduct. How can we how
in the world are we seeing the same
thing over and over and over again?
Because the fruit is rotten because the
core is rotten. If the core is rotten,
you cannot have good fruit from from bad
from from a a bad tree, right? So,
it's unbelievable.
Um, so anyway,
that that that was last year that it all
came out. But from the Kansas City
prophets comes the nep apostolic
reformation the third wave um and also
the John Wimber with the vineyard
movement uh that that that is in between
all of that. Uh so if people know about
the vineyard movement that's a whole
there's a lot of church that's called
vineyard that is also part of that whole
um group that is that is uh looking to
uh um manifestations uh experience etc.
So that's where where that all comes
from and I think it was the Toronto
blessing was a vineyard church where the
whole Toronto happening. Uh John Wimberg
came out of the um and uh I think John
Wimber, James G, Jay, Patricia King, all
of those came out of um uh um the
movement that we talked about last video
about Tate um Chapel um
Calvary Chapel Calvary Chapel movement
and the Calvary Chapel movement. That's
where where these guys are coming from
and they wanted more experience as well,
right? So, but the if we go back to that
movement, the the the the start of that
movement was the Jesus people, Lonnie
Frisbee. What was he? He was a drug and
he was he was gay. I'm
why do we see all these things coming
again and again and the whole Calvary
Chapel movement birthe the CCM, right?
So Tate and all the the those things,
I'm like, why do we see it over and over
again and again and again? Because
because Satan has
It's true. Yeah. Because Satan has an
agenda to take over
Christianity. He He his whole mission is
to deceive the Christians. He He doesn't
have to even mess with the lost world.
They're lost. his
aim, his we are his target. So he's
infiltrating with Jesuits and uh
Freemasons and all this stuff to get
into the church to corrupt the the
doctrines and all that. Um and so yeah,
we do we keep seeing this it's the best
cover too for if you are some sexual
predator
become a part of a church, right?
Because now people will trust you,
right? Become a priest even better.
People really they they come to you and
they confess all their sins to you. So a
pastor or whatever.
That is like the best cover story.
You're the least likely suspect in that
case. And and just look at you you
mentioned Tate. I don't know if people
watching realize you're talking about
Michael Tate, frontman of the News Boys,
who all this is just now coming out that
he is a a sexual predator, like a a drug
addict, an alcoholic, and a sexual
predator for 20 years in the music
industry. I'm ashamed to say I've seen
the band like six times. I gave him
personally one of my t-shirts from my
old clothing line. And you know, I I
cried reading his I got emotional
reading his apology letter because I
hate seeing that
we can fall into this. Like I don't I
don't know where he's at. I don't know
if he had like some big sinister thing
like well if I pretend to be in a
Christian band I can get away with this
stuff. But 20 years your conscience the
Holy Spirit has to be convicting you at
some point. And he didn't even come out
until he got caught from what I
understand. So it wasn't like I can't
hold the secret anymore. I gotta I
gotta, you know, confess and repent and
turn myself in, you know, lock me up. It
wasn't anything like that that I'm aware
of.
And so well have to add also I also have
to add that the research that has been
done by the Roy report uh was a year and
a half. So there has been already
investigations.
Uh so in the year and a half he never
came out either, right? So it came it
probably became too he too too hot under
his feet. So he he got out of out of the
news boys and and you know tried to to
uh how do you say it? Uh be prepared or
something like that. But then again, he
never said anything until he got exposed
after the first article came out. Then
that was the time that he came out with
a public public confession. Why didn't
he do it beforehand? Yeah. Um but I mean
that all that aside, like it's a trend
at the moment. You see Carl Lens, right?
Uh with cheating, you see uh over and
over again and again you see these these
things. uh Robert Morris, another mega
Jewish pastor who uh had 20 years ago
who who had an affair or four fif I
don't know how many years ago 30 years
had an affair with with an underageed
girl for a long time abusing her. So uh
and that's also an N leader, right? So
all from that the all from the the same
the same roots comes all from the same
roots. You
a bad tree cannot produce good fruit.
Yeah. You'll know them by their fruits.
I mean that's what we're seeing. Yeah.
So now we have so so if we go to Kansas
City profits then after if you go to the
next slide that's where your your your N
kind of like uh uh steps in and then you
have CP Peter Wagner here he is he is
kind of like the father figure to great
men and women as they say great men and
women such as Chuck Chon Cindy Jacobs
Rick Warren John Maxwell John Kelly as
well as advisor and friend of many more
and obviously the first pre presiding
apostle of international coalition of
apostles now ICEL from the inception in
uh until he handed over the broad the
broad movement of apostles in 2010.
So I mean you see in the pictures you
see John C. Maxwell he is part of it. um
the Skyline Church uh Jim Carlo was uh
after him and Jim Carlo is an icon
member. So they have been all in the
movement. Um Cindy Jacobs is is is a big
one there. James G Rick Warren was um so
C. Peter Wagner was uh teacher and a
faculty uh um uh uh the Fuller
Theological Seminary. Um and uh
basically Rick Warren was his student.
So that's how they met. And they are
really they've been really setting up
the the whole um um seeker sensitive and
and growth church growth model like how
can you grow your church uh uh together
with the secular guy Peter Ducker who
was also an occultist. And Rick Warren
even calls uh Peter Ducker his mentor.
And Rick Warren also uh calls um what's
the guy from the the glass cathedral? Ca
cathedral. Um I don't know. That sounds
familiar.
Mueller. Uh um
uh what's his name? I forgot his name
again. Um Schuler. Robert Schuler. Okay.
He was he was a 33rd degree Freemason.
Wow. and he was a he he was a a student
of Norman Vincent Peele who was a 33
degree Freemason, right? So the
connections are all over the place.
Yeah. So and now you have your IEL where
C. Peter Wagner is is kind of like
overseeing and created the new apostolic
reformation basically.
So um so he was also the one that that
coined the term new apostolic
reformation. So if people are saying I
don't know what the new apostolic
reformation is. Well uh he he he coined
that ter that term and I have a video
later on where he is even saying that uh
that phrase new apostolic reformation.
So it's on tape right so he invented it.
So all these so-called prophets and
apostles that are denying that the N
exists because there are people that are
denying it. Michael Brown, uh Mh
Daniel Kenda and other people are
heavily saying the NAR doesn't exist.
It's a conspiracy theory. It does exist
and everybody is looking up towards C.
Peter Wagner. I have footage of
everything. nconnections.com
is the website that I create that I
created where where you see all the
footage of all these people all together
intermingling. Um I mean it's insane and
CPA Wagner coined that term. So it does
exist. No, it doesn't have a building.
No, it doesn't have a denomination. It
doesn't have an office. Well, they have
an office with Ikel.
But so if you search uh if you go to
search, you can search all the names
that are in in the new episode of
Reformation. So this is Minnow's website
narconnections.com
and then you can click by name uh and
you can also look on on the on the under
one of the the letters.
Wow.
So I'm going see if I recognize any
names in here.
So, not all of them have uh have links
yet. Uh there's so too many, man. Dude,
this is a lot of research. Oh my. What?
All these people are somehow affiliated
with I mean, we're still in the A's,
too.
Oh my, this is a huge list. Okay, so who
who could I go to? Uh what's uh what's
that guy's name? We were just watching
him with the long dreadlocks. Um,
why I can't think of his name right now?
Todd White. Todd White. I don't have
his, but Bill Johnson. The one that Bill
Johnson. Yeah, Todd White. I don't know
if I have You can try.
The list is still growing.
Bill
up. No. Go up up. You go down. Up.
Bill. Yep. Bill Johnson. Wow, dude. So
there you see basically uh the
information and you see also like what
what who who is I looked at all his link
all his links with that uh
yeah so so uh who is he is he endorsing
on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. So,
who does he who does he endorse, right?
And also on the left side, you see what
he's part of? Um, Council of Prophetic
Elders, the ACPE. Um, and funny enough,
the ACP. Uh, you have heard of the the
the Passion Translation? Oh, yeah. Brian
Simmons, he's part of the ACP as well,
the Apostolic Council.
I want to explain to people because
there's so much stuff that we talk about
that we just know that I don't know if
everybody knows, but the Passion
translation is a paraphrased Bible from
a guy who said that an angel appeared to
him, manifested and appeared to him
named Passion and told him a new
translation of the Bible to write. And
this is a Bible that people are starting
to pick up and read because it's easier
to read. It sounds so loving and all
these things. But an angel told a man,
God's word isn't good the way it is. I
need you to write it this way, that is
not an angel. Uh this that's not a a
good angel. Remember, there's good and
angel, good and bad angels. And Satan
appears as an angel of light. This angel
named Passion,
God's word has withtood for thousands of
years. There's no reason to make a new
translation.
Yeah, it's insane. And uh so and there
you see screenshots that I took right
with with that on the right side. Oh no,
if you go down go down one more yeah
this one on the right side you see
Daniel Kanda who denies that NR exists.
He's he's he's he's uh naming names like
oh people that believe the N are
conspiracy theorists that are sitting in
their basement doing videos like this.
Wow. Insulting people. Uh, and he's
sitting next to Bill Johnson who is
writing invading Babylon and the seven
mountain mandate. Right. So, uh, what do
you mean it doesn't exist? It does
exist.
Wow.
There you have Jensen Franklin who is uh
uh that's another guy. But if you go
there, Jensen Franklin, who's next to
Trump all the time. Oh,
interesting. He uh is always with Trump.
Uh all the connections,
all the connections, man. The political
realm, the religious realm,
it's all setting the stage for this
Antichrist system. Benny Hen. Yeah.
Wow. So, old school and new school.
Yeah. So, videos exposing him. Some of
them are taken down by people.
Wow, man. Great resource. Check it out,
guys. narrations.com.
That's Minnow's official website. Great
work, bro.
Thank you. Thank you. So, if you go back
to the to the the page um the where
we're at. So, I is official
organization. So, with ICAL um so it's
kind of like a pyramid scheme kind of.
So, apostles if you want to become an
apostle, you have to pay if you uh but
you get discount. You know when you get
discount if if you bring your wife in
you have couple disc ladies night but
anyway you can pay to pay to be be a an
apostle right so and it cost you a
couple of hundred bucks a year or
whatever it's a membership but
like how how in the world yeah I mean oh
I I think that there's some connections
there for sure oh yeah we've seen it
already right so uh But at the end of
the day, like man, uh, did Peter or Paul
or anybody pay any dues to become an
apostle?
I didn't just collecting like did you
give Hey, uh, Peter, you didn't pay.
That's why they had a treasure box.
That's the treasure box. Oh, that's
right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Wow, man. But
yeah, it's it's insane. So is kind of
the organization from C. Peter Wagner,
right? and and from there flows other
organizations and they also have uh
people under him. So Chayan is in the
middle of the pictures um the Chinese or
the the the Asian looking guy. He alone
has like 50,000 churches under him. Oh
wow. 50,000
churches. How many Bill is
Chuck Pierce? We call him the Santa
Claus. Oh yeah, we got um Kenny Rogers
is in it. KFC, Colonel. Kia. I know.
Colonel Sandia. It's insane. But uh so
there's another guy called Bill Haymon.
He also has like 50,000 churches
underneath him. So there's a lot of
churches that are underneath and they
need they need to be above these
churches. They need to lead and uh the
churches need to obey basically the
their spiritual leaders, those apostles
because they're superior. That is scary,
man. 50 thou to think that 50,000
churches are that's only one one guy,
right? One guy
has another 50,000. Yeah. Just to think
of 50,000 church like false churches
alone is horrifying. But that's just
under one guy.
Yeah. Wow, man.
Seriously, it's it's bizarre. Um, and if
you go to the next slide,
so there you see uh C. Peter Wagner uh
you know, he he basically uh leading and
building the new Apostolic Reformation
uh prophetic uh and he was really into
spiritual warfare. Uh, and that's kind
of his uh his um uh that's what what
ties in and that's where you got spirit
of uh territorial spirits uh that you
have to remove. Uh but if even an
archangel and forgive me it was Michael
or whoever it was that would not even
rebuke Satan.
How in the world can we rebuke Satan?
Right. Yeah. I mean,
and they are rebuking and and and and uh
and storming the the heavens uh against
all these these demonic forces and doing
spiritual warfare that way. Well, that's
not how spiritual warfare works, right?
Um but anyway, that that ties in into
that whole seven mountain mandate,
right? That you have to take over these
these de demonic and uh spheres and then
Christianize it. Um, but yeah, he was
part of the Fuller Theological Seminary.
And then you see uh underneath you see
the the a photo of of the guy that I was
talking about um with the 50,000
churches. This Asian guy.
No. Uh the the the picture was from
um I'm looking now. Uh
what was his name? Was Peter Ducker? Was
he on the previous page?
No, the one that you're looking at now.
I'm I'm
I did put this presentation together
like Peter Ducker right there. Small.
Yeah. Yeah, Peter Ducker. So, right
there. So, I think that's Peter Ducker.
Uh the guy that we talked about. But
anyway, all that said, uh it's it's uh
his Peter uh Peter um see Peter Wagner
even had a book called uh called
Dominion uh we have to take dominion
over over the earth. M um he has a
Wagner University and that's highlighted
an an unacredited institution which
trains revivalists
and reformers to bring about a global
movement of transformation.
Wow. Okay. What kind of transformation?
Uh spiritual nature but not the spirit
of God. Right. Yeah. What kind of
spirit?
Yeah. And you see it more and more are
happening, right? The stadiums,
revivals, and um it's getting bigger and
bigger and and and at some point things
are going to happen because they're uh
in invoking this, right? And uh and
something is going to happen. We all
know that that something's going to
happen. Yeah. Um but it's not of God.
Doesn't mean that it is of God.
Yeah. Yeah. So the next slide uh is uh
Peter uh uh Peter this is C. Peter
Wagner and then after him comes Dutch
sheets uh one of his apostles and they
going to explain uh like uh uh in a
nutshell what the what their aim is what
they want to do. Dominion has to do with
control. Dominion has to do with
rulership. Dominion has to do with
authority and subduing.
My name is Peter Wagner and I'm speaking
to you here from Colorado Springs from
the Wagner Leadership Institute where in
our institute we teach very strongly on
the seven mountains and we teach for
social transformation.
My point is
that we're in the second apostolic age
and and the government of the church
must be in place with apostles and
prophets
which brings us to the dominion mandate.
Now first of all I want to point out
these two words dominion and mandate.
The word mandate, you've got to
understand, mandate means an
authoritative order or command. It
doesn't mean a good idea. It doesn't
mean a suggestion. It means an
authoritative order. Dominion has to do
with control. Dominion has to do with
rulership. Dominion has to do with
authority and subduing. And it relates
to society. Dominion means being the
head and not the tail. Domin dominion
means ruling as kings. It says in
Revelation 16 that he has made us kings
and priests. And check the rest of that
verse. It says for dominion. Jesus
delegated establishing his kingdom to
us. What do I mean? To you and to me.
We are the ones who are the who are
supposed to bring this about. See Jesus
tra trained his disciples to take charge
after he left. Go ahead and put the
first map up on the screen if you would.
These are just circles. The blue circles
represent apostolic networks. We have
them all over the nation. Now, I'm just
deal with America. They're all over the
world, but we have them all over
America. The black dots represent
individuals.
There is an awesome apostolic grid.
There is an apostolic prophetic grid.
There's an apostolic prophetic
intercession declaration
grid over America. We are positioned now
to do anything he wants to do. And
they're out there. Believe me, they're
everywhere. There are apostles in the
military. There are apostles in
government. There are prophets in
government. There are apostles and
prophets in the media.
They are there in entertainment. They
are there in education. You have no idea
what God is about to unleash on this
nation.
He was just naming some of the pillars
right there.
Yep. Uh Exactly.
Yeah. Wow.
What he's saying? We have no idea what
their God is unleashing on this nation.
Right. I I don't see anything in the
Bible about Christ is going to change
the world and it's everything's going to
be like God's perfect kingdom here on
earth. Not until much much later anyway.
And it's going to be once the earth is
cleansed of all unrighteousness. It's
going to he's going to come and we're
going to be caught up to meet the Lord
in the air and the wicked are going to
be destroyed by the brightness of his
coming. And then after a thousand years,
he will touch the ground and there'll be
a whole judgment of the wicked and
everything. But that's when there's
perfect peace on earth. Only then, only
after the wicked are destroyed in the
lake of fire. It never talks about that
there's going to be ever a perfect
world. It talks about how terrible the
world is going to be. It's going to be
full of boasters and disobedient
children and haters of godliness and
you'll be hated for my name's sake.
You'll be persecuted. Your brother will
turn against brother and father against
son and all this stuff. Where is all
that message? Where are they getting
this?
not from well twisting scripture and and
what they believe they twist they twist
uh uh so when you hear Peter Wagner see
Peter Wagner say about uh dominion that
you have to take dominion over the earth
what they believe is Adam lost dominion
over the earth but Jesus restored it so
now it's our job to take it back is that
what the Bible says no it doesn't
it's Christ it's not ours that's Right.
That's a good point.
Yeah. Satan has the keys and then
Yeah. But basically, if we have to do
it, what does that make us? If we have
to do it, makes us God. But that's what
these Yeah. That's what these people
preach. They say you are little gods,
little G. You know that stuff. Benny
Hen, Creo, Dollar, all these guys said.
This is a perfect intro into the next
slide. Perfect intro to the next slide.
Word of faith and new apostolic
reformation. What do they have in common
with the Vatican, Freemasonry, and the
New Age? Go to the next slide. Wow. And
hit start. And hit start. And if God now
produces man
and everything produces after its own
kind,
if horses get together, they produce
what?
And if dogs get together, they produce
what? If cats get together, they produce
what?
But if the godhead gets together and
say, "Let us
make man," then what are they producing?
They're producing gods.
Now, I got to hit this thing real hard
in the very beginning because I ain't
got time to go through all this. But I'm
going to say to you right now, you are
God's. Little G. You are God's because
you came from God. And you are God's.
You're not just human. The only human
part about you is this physical body
that you live in. Do you know what else
that is settled then tonight? this hue
and cry and controversy that has been
spawned by the devil to try and bring
dissension within the body of Christ
that we're gods. I am a little God.
Yes, I have his name. I'm one with him.
I'm in covenant relationship. I am a
little god. Critics, you are not
anything that he is. Yes.
God came from heaven, became a man, made
man into little gods,
went back to heaven as a man. He faces
the father as a man. I face devils as
the son of God.
You see what I'm talking about? You say,
Ben, am I a little god? You're a son of
God, aren't you? You're a child of God,
aren't you? You're a daughter of God,
aren't you? What? What else are you?
Quit your nonsense. What else are you?
If you say I am, you're saying I'm a
part of him, right? Is he God? Are you
his offspring? Are you his children? You
can't be human.
Go ahead. You tap into who you really
are. You know what the Bible calls you?
It says you are little Elohim. You are a
little God. in the battle where he says
I am. I just smile and say yes I am too.
Listen I think this kind of gets the
point across. He said you know why do
people have such a fit about
God calling his creation his creation
his man not his whole creation but his
man little gods. If he's God what's he
going to call him but the god kind. I
mean if you as a human being have a baby
you call it a human kind. If if cattle
has another cattle they call it cattle
kind. So, I mean, what's God supposed to
call us? Doesn't the Bible say we're
created in his image? Then the Jews took
up stones again to stone him. Of course,
you know, Jesus answered them, "Many
good works I have shown you from my
father."
He never takes credit himself.
For which of those works do you stone
me? The Jews answered him, saying, "For
a good work, we do not stone you, but
for blasphemy, because you be a man,
make yourself God." See, a lot of people
don't want to hear that you're little
gods.
How dare you?
Really, I don't know about you, but
Jesus is my Lord and Savior, and it's
right here. Came out of his mouth, not
my mouth. Is it not written, I said, you
are gods?
If he called them gods to whom the word
of God came, didn't the word of God come
to you? Hello. And the scripture cannot
be broken. Do you say of him whom the
father sanctified and sent into the
world? You are blaspheing because I said
I am the son of God. He was the son of
God. And you are little gods because you
have the son of God living, breathing,
and dwelling inside of you. The reason
why you can heal the sick, raise the
dead, and cast out demons is because of
who you are. Jesus didn't say, "Pray for
the sick." He said, "Heal the sick."
Well, only God can heal the sick. That's
why he said the imitators of God.
Listen, I can't heal the sick. Only God
can heal the sick. That's right. You are
sons of God.
In fact, Jesus quoted the psalmist when
he said, "You are God's and the word
God's is little G. Ye is big G and you
are little G.
You're little G, God." I understand
we're not Mormons. Don't take this too
far.
I'm saying that before you were born
again, you were created a little lower
than the angels, but when you got born
again, the angels serve you. Say after
me, within me. Within is a God man. God.
Say it again. within me is a God man.
Now let's say it even better than that.
Let's say I am a god man.
Who
was the biggest loser?
Satan.
No.
God. Who you are. Turn to Psalm 82. This
is going to blow your mind real good.
Psalm 82:1. God standeth in the
congregation of the mighty. That's you.
He judgeth among the what? Now, would
you please listen to me? This is talking
about you.
He's telling the gods.
Who are the gods?
You are. See, I never heard that. Let me
ask you this. Hello, you. Are you God's
offspring?
Then you're not human,
dude.
So I've heard a lot of these and it just
were the faith guys and also the the
apostolic reformation all the same the
same rthoric right like little little
gods. Yeah.
It just blows my mind. What do they
think they are? Yeah. And you cannot
base entire doctrine off of one verse
anyway. The Bible says by the mouth of
two or three witnesses. It says study to
to um line upon line, precept upon
precept, hear a little, there a little,
by the mouth of two or three witnesses.
So, they can't give any other verse.
They're giving this verse. And like I do
with anything, if one verse seems to
contradict a hundred other verses that
clearly say we are not gods or or
something like that, then there has to
be something deeper to study about that
one verse.
Absolutely.
Absolutely. But but where do you where
do you think that that the theory comes
from? Oh, it comes from the Garden of
Eden when the serpent said, "You will be
as gods, knowing good and evil. Eat this
fruit, your eyes will be open."
That's right. That's right. But but if
we go a little bit recent, if you go to
the next slide, we see the little god's
doctrine in the Vatican. Oh,
interesting. Well, that's the serpent
right there. The catechism. the
catechism of the the the it shows you on
on top the the link and it says here the
word became flesh to make us partakers
of the divine nature. For this is why
the word became man and the son of God
became the son of man. So so that man by
entering into communion with the word
and thus receiving divine sunship might
become a son of God. For the son of God
became man so that we might become God.
The only begotten son of God wanting to
make us sharers in his divinity assumed
our nature so that he made man might
make man gods. What on earth? Wow. That
is the same lie as you mentioned from
the Garden of Eden. Yeah.
And I'm like kind of curious to look at
the back to the Vatican again, right?
Yeah. All eight hall roads lead to Rome
man.
Wow.
Does the do so the doctrine is not is is
not only coming from these prosperity
teachers and the n it comes straight
from the fatican too. And it goes even
further. If if we go one slide further
we go to morals and dogma. I didn't I
was not able to highlight it but there's
there is in in this text there is uh
it's talking about divinity right that
we are divine it's it's it's in
freemasonry it's in the new age
so here moral and darkness right here
Lucifer the son of the morning
light yeah Lucifer the lightbearer
I these this is morals and dogma is one
of
the most well-known Freemason books
written by Albert Pike, one of the most,
you know, acclaimed
Freemasons. And he's saying that they
worship Lucifer the Lightbearer right
there in the book. Yep. Absolutely.
So, uh, and then the next slide is Manly
Pi Hall. Same thing. He's writing of
also of of uh you know the that man is
divine
the eye of self
I oh the law freemasonry yeah
the little god's doctrine wow dude
and he calls it the the brahma the
vehicle of Brahma and then you have the
next slide the yeah the the secret
doctrine of Helena Blavasi Again, she's
talking about uh that that we are
divine, a divine spark and and um
unbelievable.
Wow. So, this is the heavenly man. The
word the heavenly man, right? And then
you have Alice Bailey and how many times
comes in there? Yeah.
St till the consciousness eventually is
divine. Right. So you as the the
so you're um it is the prog progressing
for from a consciousness polarized in
the personality lower self or body to
that polarized in in the higher self ego
or soul uh then to the polarization in
the the monot whatever or spirit till
the consciousness eventually is divine
right that's exactly what They mean you
can become divine.
Wow, dude. And and Alice Bailey, the UN
adopted her writings. And so now we're
starting to see this combination of
church and state and this religion, the
universal religion that's coming soon.
That's literally Luciferianism. And you
can prove it. one of our first episodes,
remember that Trump was uh was
inaugurated under the Masonic uh uh
George Washington being deified, right?
Y so I mean everything points to that
same thing being divine being gods.
Yeah. and him saying that we're entering
into the golden age which is the age of
Aquarius and Alice Bailey or Helen
Bavski I can't remember which one said
that at 2025 would be the u the
hierarchy of the what is it the uh
externalization of the hierarchy which
is demons manifesting in our world I
mean this whole thing everything this is
not a coincidence man everything is
setting up for the beast right now
Yeah, if you go to the next slide, you
see here atonement for her means on all
levels, emotional, institutional, uh,
intuitional, spiritual and divine. Oh
man.
And then the next slide uh you see that
uh the immortal destiny of each and all
of us is to attain the consciousness of
the higher self and subsequently that of
the divine spirit. So that you have to
become divine.
Just so anyone out there doesn't know,
this is not a Christian woman. She is an
occultist. No, no, no. Yeah. I mean,
everything is uh that you go in the
higher mind is literally his divine
ancestor. I mean,
seriously, uh unbelievable. And then the
next slide, we're going through this one
quickly, but the next slide here, you
see the her website. Uh that's this is
uh the her website here. It's she talks
about the Christ within, right?
[Music]
The reappearance of Christ. See, these
people, these newagers, they're so
crafty. And I don't think it's them,
it's it's Satan, but is so crafty about
making this stuff look Christian. I
mean, if I just saw this website, I'd
think, oh, what what uh mega church is
this? you know, like this totally looks
Joe or Kenneth Copelan. And then I see
the reappearance of the Christ and I'm
like, "Oh, okay." Uh, but it's all about
this Christ within, Christ
consciousness. And that's what's so
tricky about the new age is that you can
have a new age book and it it could be
scripture after scripture after
scripture, but it's all junk like this,
like you're you are gods and uh your
eyes will be open, you shall be as gods,
and the god within and all that stuff.
Wow. Yep.
Here. And then the next slide uh
especially the first sentence here that
which off offset the sense of
frustration and fertility and provide
likewise the needed incentive towards
the rebuilding of the new world will be
the belief in the essential divinity of
humanity.
Oh, divinity of humanity.
Man, there's nothing in the Bible that
ever talks about even even in the new
earth, it doesn't talk about man being
divine.
Yep. And then the next slide here is
Luces Trust. That's the same website,
but the books the externalization of the
hierarchy. And uh it says number one,
humanity is evolving into divinity.
Really? Wow.
Interesting. And what and what did we
see uh what did we hear the guy say of
the uh William will William Brandham uh
that he was talking about uh the true
Christ is not the unique son of God or
something like that right I mean it's
all the same doctrine. Yeah.
Wow man. I actually uh it's been a while
since I've read some of these points
here.
The true Christ is not the unique son of
God. but one among many enlightened
masters. That's what I'm saying. Like
there's so many people that want to say,
you know, we shouldn't talk about
doctrine and this is all dividing and
let's just agree to disagree and and
come together on what we agree on, which
is Jesus. I remember there was there was
a big men's conference years ago and the
guy on stage said at the sound of three
everyone yell out your denomination. It
was just like like you couldn't tell. He
said now at the sound of three everybody
yell Jesus and it was Jesus. He said
doesn't that sound beautiful? And you
know, and I'm not big on denominations
and stuff like that, but I'm big on
truth. And you cannot div you cannot
just say, well, I agree to disagree on
truth. Um, and so let's just well, Jesus
is the truth. We all agree on Jesus.
Let's let's just come together on that.
Well, which one? The Mormon Jesus, the
new age Jesus. There's some newagers out
there that are talking to Jesus more
than most Christians.
And he's one of the many ascended
masters. It's not Jesus. It's not the
true Jesus. So, you can't just say,
"Well, let's let's all just come
together and unite on Jesus." Because
you could have all kinds of people
coming together with all kinds of
different ideas and, you know, face to
face with Jesus and the Mormon Jesus,
the new age Jesus.
It's going to be one. It's going to be
the ecumenicism is what it's going to
be.
Absolutely. Absolutely. If you go to the
next slide,
it's all highlighted, but the first
sentence again, this approach of the
central fact of human evolution, the
steady growth of divinity and the
revelation through man of divine powers.
Okay. Yes. Wow.
will offset the the fanciful fantastic
presentation of the hierarchy which has
colored all the occult movements and the
various theosophical and roian
presentations. So here you see Roseians
in there lumped in as well. Um
yeah it's
you can pause the video and you can read
it all for yourself uh if you want to.
We don't we don't have to go into the
whole thing. But again, it's all about
divine divine. Man is divine. Man is
divine. Man is God, right? And it's the
same message as these preachers.
Great. So where do they get the message
from? From these people. Yep. There must
be a link there, right? We're presenting
evidence.
Yeah.
So, um then the next uh let's see here.
Where was the one that I wanted to talk
about?
[Music]
Oh, yeah. Here the last the last alinia
of the the key to the hierarchy and it's
a reappearance on earth is phys is is in
physical form and the consequent
materialization of the kingdom of god
among man is the simple truth of god
imminent. It is the clue to the
evolutionary process and the eternal
hope of all forms in all kingdoms in
nature. This is the central truth of
what they believe. Of course, the the
convincing truth and the re revealing
truth which will underly all information
and the hierarchy and this the coming
generation of disciples will distribute
it. If this truth is factual and
possible of demonstration then the fact
of the hierarchy is proved and the
authenticity of the eternal existence of
the kingdom of God on earth is
established. Kingdom on earth. Wow.
Kingdom now. Wow. Oh, disciples.
She's talking about disciples coming
back. Yeah. Yeah. No. Well, uh the but
but what I'm highlighting here is the
kingdom of God on earth established,
right? That's what the N wants the
kingdom here on earth and then bring it
to God. Like see here it is. This is
pure a cold doctrine. Yep. Came from
Alice Bailey.
So if you go to the next one, which just
to show what Lucius Trust is, it used to
be called Lucifer's Trust, but it it's
been picked up by the United Nations.
Like her agenda
is like the playbook for the United
Nations like their goals.
So here you see what is what is
unbiblical and what is biblical, right?
So Alice Bailey says, "Man becomes
divine through evolution." Well, solos
scriptura says man is sinful and must be
born again. Amen.
Then all religions are valid paths is
what Ellis Bailey teaches and what a lot
of those preachers say. But God says sol
scripture that Christ is the only way to
the father. You mentioned that before as
well. Amen. Alice Bailey Christ is just
one enlightened master. Well, the Bible
says Jesus is the only begotten son of
God.
Alice Bailey teaches God in everything
is the central truth. Well, solos
scriptures says God is holy separate
from his creation. He's not in
everything. Amen. And then Alice Bailey
teaching here Christ will return
physically to unify religions. Well,
it's all scripture saying the real
Christ returns glory not to compromise
with other faiths. That's right. Wow,
dude.
Yeah, man. It's uh it's really crazy to
just see the time that we're living in.
All the signs pointing to us living in
the last days.
So, now we're going to compare it side
by side. So, next slide. So Alice Bailey
like Bllovaskki taught that man becomes
God that Lucifer is misunderstood as a
bringer of light and that the ultimate
goal is for humanity to evolve
spiritually into divinity and join the
hierarchy guiding global consciousness.
This teaching mirrors the Catholic
catechism deificification language as we
just read free masonic esoterism and
even new age doctrines all rooted in the
original satanic lie ye shall be as
gods. The new apostolic reformation and
many word of faith prosperity gospel
preaches as we saw also uh promote the
teaching that aligns disturbingly well
with the same you shall be as God's
light that runs through Catholicism myst
Catholic Catholic mysticism Freemasonry
and theosophy they often base it on the
twisted interpretation of Psalm 82 vers6
ye are gods taken completely out of
context and apply it to support the
doctrine that humans, especially born
again believers, have divine status or
creative power like God. Like Bill
Johnson here on here down here from
Bethl Church in California. If Jesus
Christ performed his earthly miracles as
God, he says, I stand amazed. But if he
did them as a man, dependent on God, I'm
compelled to follow his lead. So you
want to be God, right? Yeah.
It's so it's so subtle and crafty
because
as Christians, we are supposed to follow
after Christ. We're supposed to live
according to his will and follow. He's
our leader. And Jesus was fully man,
fully God, fully man. And he depended
upon God for everything. He said, "I do
nothing of myself." You know, he always
went to the father for everything. And
when he left, he said, "You will do
greater things than I. You're going to
cast out devils, heal the sick, raise
the dead, and all that stuff." But we
already know what these guys say. They
say, "You are God. You're created in his
image. You are God's." They're not
saying, "We want to be fully surrendered
to the Father and we want him to work
through us." They're saying, "No, the
power of life and death is in your
tongue." I've heard these these guys
talk about all this stuff, man. Yeah.
They're saying you speak it, you
manifest it.
It's all about you being God. Yeah.
Yeah. You you you create your own
destiny. Yeah. That's again it's it's
all the same lie. Little God's doctrine.
If you go to the next slide,
um now I have to see here uh in there
it's it says the same thing. He
performed miracles, wonders, and signs
as a man in right relationship to God.
Dot dot dot not as God.
So he then he says if he performed
miracles because he was God, then they
would be unattainable for us. But if he
did them as a man, I'm responsible to
pursue his lifestyle. So basically, you
want to become God.
Wow. Again, it's in his book or heaven
invades earth.
Wow. Bill Johnson from Beth. That's the
doctrine. The little god's doctrine.
Yeah. And even that Jesus laid aside his
divinity.
That is kinosis. That is uh also a
kinotic heresy. Yeah.
Wow. Dude, that that cover just looks
all newagy for real.
A practical guide to a life of miracles.
Yeah, I would I wouldn't know the
difference in I wouldn't even pick up
that book because I would automatically
think this is a new age book.
Yeah, they have another book uh and I
haven't put it in here, another book
called u uh physics of heaven and that
you can reclaim new age practices. Wow.
Because new age basically hijacked
biblical things and we're going to take
it back. Yep. Yep. That's like light
language. We're going to take back the
tongues and the gibberish, right?
Same thing. Same thing. and the Koreas,
the laughing like a a maniac and barking
like dogs and
Yeah. So, if you go to the next slide, I
believe uh uh what was the one that I
wanted to highlight here?
Um
uh
anointing. Um
so basically what they say is you you
need also the anointing that Christ had.
So Christ needed to needed the anointing
the experience. Uh and so um
um he had to receive the anointing in an
experience to accomplish what the father
desired. And so do we. I'm like, "Yeah,
that's not how it works." Yeah.
Oh, wow. That's not how it works. And
then the next slide, um,
the on the right top it says, "The will
of God is simply this on earth as it is
in heaven." That's also a lie that they
that they say, right? That's from the um
uh the prayer, right? And it's it's like
God's will, right? It's about God's
will. what happen what he wants that it
happens here on earth. But what they say
is no uh but what they say is like no uh
we we accomplish here on earth what uh
what uh what um uh we we command decree
and declare it and and and that's what
we what what we're proclaiming in heaven
and it also happens here on earth. I'm
like yeah that's not how it's not how we
do this like having supernatural
heavenly power or something.
Yeah. Um, do do you know Stephen
Ferdick?
Yes. Elevation. Elevation. Elevation.
Uh, so the next slide. Uh, you see some
N people again. Same concept about God
that they're the little gods. You can
hit the button. Me. I'm not in covenant
with a person. I'm not in covenant with
a political party. I'm in covenant with
God Almighty. I am God Almighty.
Get that off you. That's not your name.
That's not your station. That's not your
end.
It's in me. It's in me. And Jesus was
tempted at all points. That scripture
alone verifies that when he was here, he
walked this out as a man.
People have taken that doctrine that I
just said to you, twisted it on YouTube,
and said that Todd White takes the deity
away from Jesus. No, what you've done,
if you've taken what Jesus said he was
away from the Bible.
See, if Jesus didn't do what he did as a
man, there's nothing for us to model.
There's no model for us. And then we're
always left with, well, that was Jesus.
No. Jesus was tempted at all points. He
was tempted at points that none of us
have ever been tempted at. He was
tempted at all points for everyone in
every area. All of it. Jesus was. and he
sinned not.
He never ever ever ever gave a license
to his flesh to sin.
Guys, are you hearing me? When it comes
to the miraculous, if you don't
understand this, then you can't pray for
the sick. Why? Because that was Jesus.
I'm not Jesus. No. Jesus never healed
the sick as God. Jesus healed the sick
as a man in perfect relationship with
God. Jesus was here. The Holy Spirit
comes down upon Jesus, rested upon him
and remained. And when Jesus healed the
sick, it was God through Jesus. Jesus
said several times, he said, "You know,
if you don't believe me through the
things that I say, at least believe me
through the works that I do. For it's
the Father who dwells in me that does
the works.
He said, "My words to you are spirit and
they are life." This is stunning to me
because he says,
"Let me put it this way. Here's Jesus.
The word of God made flesh." And now
when he speaks, the word of God is made
spirit.
Something happens when you find the
heartbeat of God and you speak it. But
that that statement is made. Suddenly
there is a sense of presence that you're
not alone. What just happened? Words
became spirit and that spirit gives
life. You have more than words. You have
more than a message. You have more than
a concept. You have more than a
spiritual argument. You have a person
resting upon you that longs to be
released into the environment because
you are saying what the father is
saying.
You are the ones that are on the edge of
being able to influence culture, thought
life, atmosphere, attitude, mindsets are
changed by how you speak, what you
think, what you say, how you live. You
in infect in a godly sense infect
atmosphere so that transformation can
take place. Jesus made this scary
statement.
He said, "The son of man can do nothing
of himself."
Do you know that Jesus so restricted his
function on earth that he actually
couldn't heal anyone?
He couldn't multiply food.
He couldn't cast out devils. He couldn't
do any of that stuff
because he had restricted himself
to the life of a human being that would
have to be dependent on the father
through the Holy Spirit.
Now, if he did miracles as God, I'm
still impressed. But I I'm reduced to an
observer.
I stand back and go, "That's amazing,
God. That's amazing." But the New
Testament was different. The New
Testament shifted where everyone gets to
be involved in that which God is doing.
But do you understand? He didn't heal
anybody as God.
He did no miracles as God.
Everything he did, he did as man in
right relationship with God. That's what
he told us. He said, "The son of man can
do nothing of himself." The word nothing
in the Greek means nothing.
He said what he meant. He meant what he
said. I can't do a thing. He had so
emptied himself of divinity that he was
self-imposed restriction. He's eternally
God. Don't make any mistake. Eternally
God. He's not a created being. He's not
an ascended being. He's a He's eternally
God. But he set aside divinity. Set
aside divinity. And he modeled for us
what life could be like for anyone who
had no sin and who was completely
empowered by the spirit of God.
Everything he did. Now, if he did it as
God, I'm still impressed, but I'm not
compelled to follow. I stand back at a
distance and go, "Yay, God, come and do
it again."
But when I realize he did it as man, I
cannot stay the way I am.
I don't know. Did you know that Jesus
was born again?
Jesus was born again. He had to be. He
became sin. He was born through Mary the
first time and through the resurrection
the second time. that he was born again.
One
one
born again
human being
defeated all of hell.
I love it,
man. He's just scary, dude. Some of that
is so
subtle, man. It's like subtle, huh? It's
hard to
It's hard to not believe some of that,
you know, cuz I was just saying that. I
was saying that Jesus was fully God,
fully man. He did nothing of himself.
Um, but it's all still dependency upon
God the Father. Um,
and I know that these people don't
always laid down his divinity.
They say that he laid down his divinity,
but that's not true. Yeah. Because he
said, "I am because otherwise otherwise
if he laid down his divinity, then he's
not God. So, he cannot save us." That's
a good point. So, it's so subtle. It's
so subtle. There's a lot of truth that
he had to wield. He had to wield to the
father. That's correct. Yeah. However,
he was still God. And what did John say?
He did many miracles
because
to prove that he was what? God. God.
Yeah. That's true. Correct. Yeah. So to
say that that we have to model what he
did. No, that's not the message. The
message was what John said.
He did many miracles to prove that he
was God. That's why he did the miracles.
Amen.
Yeah, man. This and it doesn't mean that
God can do miracles, but at the end of
the day, we're we're not miracle
workers, right? And if God pray if God
heals somebody and we we pray,
Amen. Praise God. Not we're not saying
we don't believe in miracles, but we are
not miracle workers. We're not special
people with with special healing powers.
Uh we're we're not the superpower. We
don't have superpowers like that. Right.
So, and we don't have to force it. Uh
what they are saying is we uh you know,
we need to walk in it. No, we need to
pray for people. And if and and at the
end of the day, it's up to God what he
does. That's right. Right. Amen. God,
our our job is to pray. That's it. and
and pray, ask uh uh ask God for for for
healing. And and we're we cannot decree
and declare. That's right. That's what I
was going to say. Like if if this was
true what they're saying, then you have
the power to do anything in your will
because you're God. You speak it. Hey, I
need a new car. Poof, there's a new car.
Um but it's it's nothing about, you
know, what God's will is. It's about
what your will is because we're little
G's, right?
Well, uh then all the disciples or all
the apostles in the in the past, they
missed the they missed the message,
right? They all died. That's true. They
could have they could have uh overcome
all that into
existence. And Paul Paul with his thorn
in his uh in his uh in his flesh, right?
Uh three times he prayed and go away. He
didn't have faith. I like this comment
from Fallen World Films. It says, "It
was subtle from Bill Johnson, not so
much from Copelan." Lol. There's nothing
subtle about that, man. That's true,
man. He is just a Yeah, they get
craftier by they get craftier and
craftier, right? Yeah. Wow, man. But did
you see in Kenneth Copelan's video la
the last video you saw in the audience,
uh, top white, right? Where do you think
he got that whole idea from? From
Kenneth Copeland, right? Yep. Satan's
got a a tackle box full of bait, man.
He's got a flavor for everyone. So, if
you're not into Kenneth Copeland, you'll
be in the Todd White. See, I was like
that. I actually I heard Todd White's
testimony the first time I ever heard of
this guy years ago and and he uh had
this supernatural freedom from addiction
and he had powerful testimony. I was
like, "Dude, I love this guy." And I I
watched something else, a video by him
called Transformation. I sent it to
somebody and uh I thought he was going
to be like, "Man, this is great." But he
said, "You realize that guy never opens
the Bible once?" I was like, "Yeah, no,
no." And I was like, I rewatched it. I
was like, "He never opened the Bible. He
never showed a scripture on screen."
Literally doesn't have a Bible anywhere.
I mean, Todd White, I've never is. And
in the couple things that I've seen,
none of it's Bible. It's just him
talking like a like a
self-help motivational speaker or
something. Yeah. Yeah. So, that's a red
Well, and if he opens the Bible, it's to
prove something, right? Uh it's already
uh uh to to to prove text basically. Uh
yeah, take things out of context to to
prove a point, right? That's not how you
read the Bible.
So, yeah. Uh we uh the next slide uh the
charismatic movement. We already kind of
talked a little bit about it. Um uh the
congregate. So so you have the
charismatic movement. Then you have the
reformed. I already mentioned that
right? So you have the Presbyterian
churches uh which profess the
traditionally Calvinist and reformed
theology. But there's some uh different
um uh different people that are in a
reformed uh uh camp that are
um uh how how do I say it? They have the
uh not the reformation but they call it
restor um um restructionism of
reconstructionism
or something like that. So they are in
in the same camp. And then you have your
Roman Catholics, right? The Catholic
Church that is charismatic renewal where
that comes in. We already talked about
this. So you don't need to Oh, and and
then also there was a pope that spoke in
tongues all I think it was Pope Francis.
Yeah. Pope who?
Pope Francis. Oh, interesting. and and
and I believe that it was the Bethl
guys, Bill Johnson and and uh Chris
Fatin who says that also little G gods,
right? Uh they those guys had to explain
to Pope Francis what what it means to
speak in tongues. I'm like really? Wow,
that's crazy. Yeah. And I I'm not
surprised at all that it was Pope
Francis. I mean, he was on the cover of
LGBTQ magazine. and he had told a kid
that even good atheists go to heaven. I
mean, he was so off on everything.
And um these guys that were showing Todd
White, who's teaming up with Kenneth
Copeland, Kenneth Copelan had a Catholic
priest come up to the pulpit and say, "I
guess we're all Catholic now." And
everybody cheered. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Francis Chan had a bunch of priests lay
hands on him on his stage. like four
priests come over and lay hands on him
and pray for him. Uh Rick Warren is
saying we need to
unite together with the Catholic Church
and made the news him saying this stuff
recently. You see that, right? He
recently had a video again. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. It's all over the place. And and
and that's for the for our next video.
I'm gonna going to show more and more of
that connection. Todd White, same thing.
Pray to uh
Lou Angle, another prophet in the
movement. We're going to show like where
they fall into underneath who and the
hierarchy, right? And then show show
also the the the echmenism and and more
stuff. So there's a lot more coming. Um
and uh yeah, so that's kind of like
almost to the tail end. There's one
more, the shephering movement. Uh it's a
spin-off. It's kind of like a splinter
group off the the the so you had the
Kansas City prophets and then you had uh
the shephering movement at the same
time. And you have you ever heard of
cell groups, right? Yeah. The cell group
church. Yeah. Uh and there are uh the
G12 and the C12 and you have all kinds
of different uh um movements where where
the cell group church is is very very um
popular. And the shephering movement is
the precursor to that. Uh and what
they've done is so you need covering
basically. But Jesus is our cover.
Right. We don't need covering. We don't
need somebody in between Christ. We
don't need another pope in our lives.
That's right. Uh so but but you need to
submit to somebody else and that's your
covering, your spiritual father. Right.
Don't call anybody your father. That's
right. But that's the whole shephering
movement is was really uh in a way
morphed also into the whole uh um
church um um how do I say it like the
the the cell group movement and uh the
so the C12 and the G12 we go deeper into
that later because there's a whole
movement part of the whole empower 21
I'll show also that vision that they
have empower 21 with that everybody you
know gets an an um encounter with Christ
before 2033 etc. Wow. That movie is part
of that whole the whole new reformation
and it is uh the G12 movement. It it
says government of 12 and it's in the
same thing. It's also a part of that
whole uh um 12 12 and then the 13 one,
right? It's the whole the the the uh the
group of 13 that is uh uh the covens and
that kind of stuff. Um but with the G12
is like
and the shephering movement uh was first
and then G12 now it's very it comes out
of Colombia the G12 but what they say is
if you start your uh your group and the
people that come in your group are are
need to start their own group as well.
So they need covering you but then they
So, it's kind of a pyramid scheme,
right? And and and you need to obey your
leaders. And some are, of course, less
uh authorative, but some are really
authorative, like really um bossy and
demanding that you need to uh obey their
leadership. And that's where sex come in
again, right? That's where
abuse comes in again. Yep. That's where
you get your um
what are their names? Jim Jones and
who is the other guy? The Shepherd's Rod
guy.
Yeah. All these cults, they always
I think I think actually some of them
maybe the majority of them actually
start off with like good intentions. It
seems like, but something happens.
There's like an ego trip. It's a spirit
actually. There's a spirit that enters
in and uh it always goes for a bad turn
and usually
most of the time ends up in sexual abuse
and all that stuff and sometimes suicide
and all that.
Well, and sometimes it's also a power
grab, right? Because if you can be uh
you know if you if you have like that
that governmental and that uh military
militaristic mindset
uh people that are hungry for power
easily grab that power right so they
it's easy to abuse at that at that time.
So there are people coming in what
you're saying that are going from from
you know with good intentions and be
growers but there are also predators
that are coming in and and just abuse.
Yeah man. Wow dude this has been
mindblowing. Uh, I think what really
stood out to me was that Mantle and the
Freemasonry and KKK and
the Jim Jones and and seeing I like how
you did it from
uh chronological order showed where the
roots were and where we're where we're
at now. And it's just dude, there's no
convincing me that we're not near the
end. I mean, this is this is the days of
many false prophets, of lying signs and
wonders. All roads point to Rome. I
mean, that's what you're going to be
talking about next time is really how
this points to Rome.
You guys do not want to miss the next
episode with Menow even prove that some
are some are uh Knights of Malta. Some
are uh I mean I spilled the beans a
little bit here but yeah there there's
uh probably some uh some other stuff
like connections to the Mooneyies. It's
another cult and yeah there's Wow, dude.
A lot more to come. Amazing work, bro.
And I wanted to promote your website
again. Let me uh make sure I got that
pulled up here. Uh where was it?
Nconnections,
right? Yep. Nconnections.com.
[Music]
Is this showing on screen?
No, it's not showing on screen.
Uh which one is it? Sorry, guys.
Guys, make sure you check out N
connections. Minnow has done some
amazing research on here. If you guys
were interested in this and want to go
deeper, this will keep you up for hours,
I'm sure. And uh thank you so much,
Minnow, for all your research, for
sharing your time with us. I know you're
way in a different time zone right now
in Japan or uh not Japan, South Korea.
South Korea. Yeah, it is. Every time I'm
somewhere else, right? I know, man.
Traveling the world. was New York. Where
have I been? And spreading the gospel to
the ends of the earth as you do it, man.
So, thank you so much, man, for coming
on and sharing your wealth of knowledge,
for your research, and uh it's just been
awesome to talk this up with you. I
can't wait to see what you got for us
next time.
Absolutely. Stay tuned. That's right.
Thank you guys. If you enjoyed this
video, if you were blessed by it, please
give it a thumbs up. It really helps
this video get out into the algorithm so
more people can see it. We cannot do
this without you guys. If you would like
to support this ministry, you can do so
by going to candidruth.org.
We really need your support. This is our
full-time job and we are trying
everything we can to get the truth out
in a world of deception. So, you can do
so through multiple digital ways of
giving. We actually have a Patreon page
as well. Uh, we have t-shirts and merch.
If you would like to rock some cool
t-shirts that have scripture on them,
check out our website,
candidatetruth.org for those. And we
love you. We thank you. We cannot do
this without you guys. If you're new,
click that subscribe button. Click the
bell icon so you won't miss another
episode. And we will see you next time
on Candid Truth.